Bin ich wieder.
Viertelstunde früher als sonst.
Wettge...
Ach, oh, und Oma wieder am Start. Moin.
Lange nicht gesehen.
Oder übersehen vielleicht, kann auch sein.
Weil ich nichts gelesen habe von dir.
Mir kommt zumindest so voll, als warst du schon eine Weile nicht mehr da.
Moin, Leute.
Ich muss mal was sagen.
Ich muss uns mal selber loben.
Also quasi den Chat.
Den Chat und mich.
Und zwar...
Ja, hallo. Kann Twitch mal please meine Videos laden?
Ich habe heute Morgen mal ein bisschen hier durchgescrollt.
Die letzten Streams, die es so gegeben hat.
Ja, so die letzten paar Wochen.
Und ich muss sagen, das war wirklich ganz nicer Content.
Ich meine, wir hatten alles mögliche wieder dabei.
Wir haben gestern Our-Packages gebaut.
GitHub Actions uns angeguckt.
Truners angeguckt.
Zeug programmiert.
Git-Web-Frontends angeguckt.
Neue .NET 8 Features ausprobiert.
Kubernetes-Stills gemacht.
Das war wieder wirklich eine sehr...
Durchgemischtes...
Content.
Aber alles so ungefähr...
Also alles schon so aus dem Technologie-Bereich, aber schon unterschiedlich.
Also kann man nicht sagen, es ist immer das Gleiche.
Also...
Ah, dann haben wir tatsächlich sogar mal ein bisschen, bisschen JavaScript gemacht zwischendurch wieder.
Handy-Verträge rausgesucht.
Access-Points gemoddet.
So, Linux-Distros ausprobiert.
Set-Server-Challenges gemacht.
War schon wirklich cooles Zeug bei, wenn man sich das so anguckt.
Das gibt es sonst auf Twitch so nicht.
Es gibt zwar in der Kategorie...
Also auch gerade, wenn man mal hier guckt auf Twitch in...
Gibt schon auch ein paar ganz coole Sachen.
Aber in dem Umfang, muss ich sagen, wie bei mir, gibt es das eigentlich nirgendswo auf Twitch.
Ich gucke ja da ab und zu immer mal durch.
Aber so durcheinander...
Unterschiedlichste Sachen gibt es wirklich wenig, ja.
Also ich muss sagen, ich bin da eigentlich ganz zufrieden mit, wie wir die letzten paar Wochen über Stream-Stills gemacht haben.
Mal gucken.
Die meisten...
Ja, ja, ja, ja.
Ist echt so.
Ich finde das aber eigentlich ganz gut, weil mich interessieren ja auch die unterschiedlichen Sachen.
Klar, ich meine, da machen wir vielleicht nicht super krass detailliert abgedrehte Sachen.
Wobei das dann auch wiederum das Problem ist.
Spricht jetzt hier auf Twitch ja eh schon nicht jetzt irgendwie hunderttausende Arten.
Und dann eben die hunderttausende an oder so.
Und wenn man dann noch...
Wenn man eh schon so ein gewisses Nischengebiet hat...
Ich meine, IT-Kram auf Twitch, das wird jetzt nie...
Views abgreifen wie Ninja zur Fortnite-Zeit oder so.
Aber wenn man dann noch so super krass detaillierte Sachen macht, wo dann von diesen Nischenzuschauern auch nur noch fünf Stück durchblicken.
Dann ist vielleicht doch ein bisschen schwierig.
Ja, es gibt zum Beispiel Leute...
Die entwickeln im Stream an ihrem C++ Zeug rum.
Und da guckst du rein, denkst dir, Alter, das ist ein Projekt mit 300 Dateien drinne.
Ich blick da nicht durch, ich mach's gleich weiter.
Geht mir zumindest manchmal so.
Und es liegt vielleicht auch ein bisschen daran, weil es C++ ist.
Weil niemand, der freiwillig noch irgendwie halbwegs bei Verstand ist.
Na doch, im Game-Bereich schon.
Game Development.
Das war eines der Sachen.
Da lass ich's mir noch gefallen.
Aber ansonsten macht C++ einfach nur Kopfweh.
Es hat schon seine Anwendungszwecke, ja.
Auch für Microcontroller oder Web-Assembly-Zeug.
Aber es ist abartig.
Und jedes Mal, wenn ich mir C++-Konferenzen angucke, denk ich mir...
Mann, könnt ihr nicht einfach mal die Sachen ein bisschen einheitlicher und logischer machen, anstatt noch die 300.000. Sache dazu zu erfinden, die man vielleicht ab und zu...
...so einmal im Jahr braucht?
Ja, ist echt so.
Ja, bin ich.
Das ist korrekt.
Ich bin ungefähr eine Viertelstunde zu früh.
Ich kann doch wieder aufgehen.
Hast du schon mal ein Game gemacht?
Nee.
Und das ist auch nix, was mich großartig interessiert.
Das ist tatsächlich so eines der Bereiche, die mich nicht groß juckt.
Ich mein, ich kenn mich software-entwicklungstechnisch gut genug aus, dass ich mir bei Games...
...durchaus auf manche Sachen einen Reim machen kann.
Aber natürlich jetzt nicht die Details, wie man Games entwickelt und warum man es vielleicht so gemacht hat.
Ja, ich kann mir da...
...so grundlegende Sachen überlegen.
So, warum haben sie das vielleicht so gemacht?
Aber jetzt, warum man jetzt, keine Ahnung, den Baum hinter die Wand da stellt, das hab ich auch keine Ahnung.
Du hast ein Azure-Zertifikat gemacht.
Oh, nice.
Welches denn?
Bei Azure, ich hab nur ein paar Azure-Schulungen aufgezwungen bekommen.
Da wurde quasi gesagt, es wird super gerne gesehen, wenn man die macht.
Ich hatte da keinen Bock drauf, weil ich hab schon im Vorfeld mal eine Azure-Schulung gemacht.
Und eigentlich ist das komplett sinnlos, weil die Powerpoint vorlesen und man sonst nix lernt.
Ich hab irgendwie AZ-901 und AZ-400 oder irgendwie sowas gemacht.
Ja.
Diese DevOps-Schulung hab ich auch gemacht.
Ich weiß nicht, welche Nummer das ist.
Lieber auch Powerpoint ablesen.
Und langweilig als fuck.
Aber wenn man ein Zertifikat am Ende macht, dann ist es natürlich sinnvoll.
Dann hat man wenigstens was zum zeigen.
Sind die, wenn du das Zertifikat machst, sind die da auch so pingelig, dass du dich quasi filmen musst beim Zertifikat machen und nicht vom Bildschirm weggucken darfst und nicht auf den zweiten Bildschirm schauen darfst und keiner ins Zimmer kommen darf und solche Geschichten?
Sind die da auch so pingelig, wenn man das Zertifikat macht?
Das stimmt wohl.
Ja, da hast du recht.
Aber sagen wir mal so.
Das ist natürlich auch wichtig.
Wobei man sagen muss, ich glaube, das wird zunehmend unwichtiger in Zeiten von Unreal und Unity, wenn man jetzt nur Sachen machen möchte, die die schon können.
Und wenn es da nicht irgendeine Plugin für gibt.
Aber ja, gibt es ja für fast alles.
Du musstest deine Finger aufnehmen und den Raum sogar zeigen.
Ja, die sind da super pingelig mittlerweile, was Zertifikate und Prüfungen angeht.
Mit bescheißen.
Mit bescheißen ist da tatsächlich schwierig.
Ja gut, das ist ja auch der Sinn dahinter.
Wollen nicht, dass die Leute bescheißen bei ihrer Prüfung.
Du musst bestimmt auch den Bildschirm übertragen und sowas.
Ja.
Naja.
Dann machen wir mal eine Sache, die wir immer Sonntag morgens machen.
Wir gucken uns die GitHub Trends an.
Und wir werden wieder feststellen, es ist wahrscheinlich auch diese Woche 90% AI, vielleicht ein bisschen Krypto und irgendwelche JavaScript Dinger.
Aber wahrscheinlich 90% AI.
Geht schon los.
AI.
Äh.
Ich hab seriously keine Ahnung.
Was?
Okay, irgendwelches China-Chinesen Zeug.
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Just China Things.
Was auch immer das sein soll.
Ich hab den Text nicht gecheckt.
Äh, AI.
Ah, okay.
Ein Rust Text Editor.
Selbstverständlich.
Das darf natürlich auch nicht fehlen.
AI.
Nee.
Bestimmt auch AI.
Twimoji.
Ja, Moment.
Twimoji ist ziemlich verkackt.
Twimoji würde ich nicht mehr verwenden, weil Twimoji wird kein Unicode oder kriegen es nicht gebacken, Unicode 15 zu unterstützen.
Weil die Leute eine Woche, bevor sie das pushen konnten, entlassen haben.
Was nicht schlimm ist, weil es gibt einen Fork davon, die gerade Unicode 15 implementieren.
Weil Twimoji, finde ich, ist immer noch der angenehmste, der angenehmste Emoji-Font.
Also Twimoji ist das, was ich auch in meiner VM benutze für Emojis.
Wobei, wobei ich ehrlich sagen muss, ich finde die Windows 11 Emojis gar nicht mal so schlecht.
Definitiv, definitiv besser als die Windows 10 Emojis.
Die Windows 10 Emojis waren abartig.
Die hier finde ich eigentlich recht, recht cool.
Die finde ich eigentlich ganz nice.
Die Windows, die Windows 10 Emojis, die waren hässlich wie die Nacht.
Und, vielleicht fällt euch was auf, Windows hat es jetzt endlich geschafft, ein Windows Emoji dabei zu haben.
Man glaubt das fast nicht, aber die letzten Windows Versionen hatten alle kein Windows Emoji dabei.
Obwohl es das schon eben war.
Aber es gibt es ewig.
Ja.
Also ich verwende hier auch Twimoji.
Guckt, das sind diese Dinger.
Also die, die man auf Discord und Twitter auch benutzt.
Die finde ich persönlich am hübschesten, so von den ganzen Emoji-Fonts.
Gibt es irgendwelche Blob-Enjoyer bei euch?
Die Teams-Emojis?
Die Teams-Emojis sind die gleichen doch mittlerweile wie Windows 11, oder?
Nur animiert.
Sind das nicht die gleichen, nur animiert?
Ist jemand von euch Blob-Emoji-Enjoyer?
Die alten Android-Emojis mit den Blobs?
Die finde ich gehen auch noch, gehen auch noch klar.
Das ist, das ist Rofi hier.
Mit, mit ein paar Plugins.
Unter anderem einem Emoji-Picker.
Da kann man dann zum Beispiel nach Rocket suchen und finde dann hier Astronaut und mein Terminal kackt dabei ab.
Wenn man das einfügt.
Die Apple-Emojis, die sind auch okay.
Wobei ich sagen muss, die sind so im, in meinem Emoji-Font-Ranking.
Ja nur auf, nur auf dem zweiten Platz.
Also ich mag, wobei fast auf dem dritten Platz.
Mir gefallen die Windows-11-Emojis auch besser.
Ich sage als erstes, es ist nach wie vor Twimoji, also Twitter und Discord.
Und halt alle, die Emoji-Font verwenden.
Danach Windows-11. Ich, ich mag die Windows-11-Emojis.
Finde die wirklich cool.
Und danach Apple.
Die Apple-Emojis sind wahrscheinlich die, die konsistentesten.
Ich weiß nicht, wie man das sagen kann.
Die, die...
Die, ähm...
Die, die, die poliertesten so.
Die sehen halt so typisch Apple aus.
Aber ich muss sagen, ich...
Kann mir die, also ich gucke mir die lieber an als die, als die Default-Android-Emojis.
Die mag ich gar nicht.
Die Blob-Android-Emojis, die waren noch ganz okay.
Aber die neuen Android-Emojis, die gefallen mir persönlich gar nicht.
Aber am liebsten ist es mit Twimoji.
Und die Windows-11-Emojis sind auch nice.
Hast du das gelesen?
Alarmstufe rot wegen Trojaner in 3CX Softphone-App.
Telefon-Software-Font.
Telefon-Software-Font 3CX.
Ist das...
Okay, was ist betroffen?
Weltweit rund 800.000, 600.000 Kunden und 12 Millionen tägliche Nutzer.
Mit 3CX hat es einen weiteren zentralen...
Die digital signierte Softphone-App direkt vom Hersteller NT-Chartcode,
die unter anderem einen sogenannten Infostil aus...
Das BSD erhöht deshalb seine Warnung in...
Okay, da steht für...
Welche Software denn?
Wie gestern bereits berichtet, gelang es...
Der vermutlich aus Nordkorea gesteuerten Gruppe Lazarus,
die Software von 3CX mit einem Downloader zu präparieren,
der Chart-Software mittlerweile bekannt...
Okay, Windows habe ich nicht im Einsatz.
Mac habe ich auch nicht im Einsatz.
Okay, solange es nicht irgendwelche Mobile-Sachen betrifft.
Ja, solche Angriffe haben in den letzten Jahren zugenommen.
Erinnert sich noch irgendjemand an SolarWinds?
Da gab es auch...
Es kommt immer mal wieder vor, ja?
Ja, das finde ich dann immer ein bisschen blöd,
wenn der Hersteller sagt so nach dem Motto...
Ja, unsere Software war zwar virenverseucht,
aber das ist doch gar nicht so schlimm.
Jetzt müssen wir mal kurz gucken,
welche Software die eigentlich herstellen,
um ein bisschen negativ Werbung für die zu machen.
3CX Business...
Ah, die stellen solche...
solche Telefone her, okay.
Ne, den Krempel verwende ich nicht.
Aber scheiße für alle, die es verwendet haben, ja.
Oh, was ist denn SQL-Chat?
Chat-based SQL, klar.
Bestimmt, bestimmt.
Ja, natürlich, AI.
Da kann man schreiben, was man haben will,
und er generiert SQL.
Na, das ist was für mich.
SQL ist so eines meiner Schwachpunkte.
Da bin ich nicht so fit drinne.
Ich meine, ich krieg nen...
Ich krieg nen Insert hin, und nen Select,
und nen Join mit ganz viel Hänge und Würgen
krieg ich den auch noch hin,
aber dann war's das aber auch.
Aber das Schöne ist,
man kann ja glücklicherweise einfach nachgucken,
in der Suchmaschine.
Also, weiß ich...
Noch mal kurz hier was zu.
Es gibt nen Fork von Twimoji.
Nein, das wollte ich jetzt nicht anzeigen.
Inside Forks.
Es gibt nen Fork von Emoji, von Twimoji.
Ach, Discord hat auch nen eigenen Fork.
Interessant.
Was haben die da gemacht?
Sie haben aber keine Emojis hinzugefügt.
Ja, das ist natürlich blöd.
Es gibt nen Fork, und zwar...
Tja, der ist gar nicht hier dabei.
Die implementieren gerade Unicorn 15.
Das, was wahrscheinlich...
Was wahrscheinlich der originale Twimoji-Font
nie bekommen wird.
Das erste?
Hab ich verguckt?
Ah ja, das erste.
Das hier tatsächlich.
Das meine ich, ja.
Genau.
Die sind gerade dabei,
Unicorn 15 einzubauen.
Und das wird's dann irgendwann demnächst geben.
Die hoffen, dass sie bis Ende März, glaube ich, fertig sind.
Fehlen noch ein paar Sachen.
Dann hat man nämlich endlich auch das Gänse-Emoji in Twimoji drin.
Das Allerwichtigste.
Das braucht man unbedingt.
Das Goose-Emoji.
Bis Ende März haben die...
Sometime in March, tja.
Ne?
Aber gut.
Ich meine, die machen das umsonst.
Das sind ehemalige Twitter-Mitarbeiter,
die jetzt quasi ihre Arbeit von Twitter weitermachen,
ohne dafür von Twitter bezahlt zu werden.
Lull.
Die sollten...
Discord sollte die einstellen.
Und Discord sollte das jetzt weiterführen,
die Entwicklung, ey.
Wenn Twitter keinen Bock mehr darauf hat.
Also, Twimoji trainet AI, AI, AI, AI.
So, was ist diese Woche angesagt gewesen?
Bestimmt auch nur AI.
Shit.
AI, AI, AI.
AI, AI, AI, AI, AI, AI,
äh, China-Chinesen-Zeug.
Keine Ahnung.
AI, AI, AI, AI.
AI, AI.
Alter.
Nice.
Nur AI diese Woche.
Shell GPT.
Okay, zeig mal her.
Cool.
Ah, das geht nur mit API-Key.
Verstehe, verstehe.
Kann man auch im Browser verwenden.
Aber...
Find ich cool, dass es immer mehr solcher Tools gibt.
Ja, Ende März haben sie knapp verpasst.
Man muss ja auch dazu sagen,
nicht nur knapp verpasst,
sind ja irgendwie 80% der Emotis noch nicht committet.
Aber immerhin arbeiten sie dran.
Du meinst, du meinst der Twitter-Leak?
Ey, ist der nicht mittlerweile wieder entfernt?
Oh.
Ey, jeder worauf er Bock hat.
Aber ich glaube, so auf SQL von Hand hat kaum jemand Bock.
Ich hatte gestern während des Streams geschafft,
Anschlienungs zu installieren.
Zum Glück konnte ich Snapshots mit...
Ja, das ist tatsächlich sehr praktisch.
Snapshots sind eines der besten Sachen an 4Ms.
Oh, ich muss mal kurz gucken.
Ich glaube, ich habe hier noch unbenutzte,
sinnlose Snapshots rumhängen.
Nee, habe ich nicht.
Okay.
Alles klar, dann nicht.
Gut.
Habe ich sonst die Woche irgendwas Spannendes verpasst?
Irgendwas?
Gibt es schon die heiße Wochenzusammenfassung?
Die bräuchten einen Link für diese Wochenzusammenfassung.
Das ist immer so schwierig zu finden.
Ja, macOS in der VM laufen zu lassen ist nicht schwer.
Dass macOS gescheit funktioniert
und man es flüssig bedienen kann,
in der VM schon deutlich mehr.
Ach nee, die haben das komplett open source gemacht.
Windrad fürs eigene Dach.
Ich habe noch nicht mal Solarpanels auf dem Dach,
weil es aktuell zu teuer ist
und sich unterm Strich noch nicht wirklich lohnt bei mir.
Da werde ich mir wahrscheinlich kein Windrad aufs Dach bauen.
Also, die machen mir gar nicht genug Wind.
Ich wohne ja nicht an der Nordsee oder so.
Da macht es vielleicht Sinn.
Oder auf dem Berg oder so.
Gab es bei Hacker News irgendwas Interessantes diese Woche?
Best of?
Best?
50% of new NPM Packages are spam.
Das ist mir auch schon aufgefallen.
Ich habe letztens mal geguckt bei NPM.
Nierdo, danke schön für den Sub.
Ich habe letztens mal bei NPM geguckt
und da habe ich mir neue Packages angeguckt
und habe festgestellt,
das Package war gar kein
NPM-JavaScript-Package,
sondern es war nur eine Readme-Werbung
für irgendwelche illegalen Film-Downloads.
Kommt mal gucken, ob sie das in dem Artikel meinen.
Ah ne, Search.
Ja, solche Dinger gibt es dann da auch.
Oh ne, gleich wird es MonkaTos, was auch immer.
Wenn du da schon nackige Rücken siehst,
weißt du nicht, ob man im nächsten Screenshot
nackige Bubas sieht.
Da kann ich nicht weiter scrollen hier live.
Ja, das ist mir auch aufgefallen,
dass NPM extrem viel sinnlos Zeug gespammt wird.
Ich glaube, die müssten checken
in irgendeiner Art und Weise
so Verhältnis von Text zu echtem JavaScript-Code,
wobei das auch nichts bringt.
Wobei das auch nichts bringt,
weil dann machen die Leute einfach
irgendwelches Chat-GPT-Generated-JavaScript da rein,
dass es halt nach JavaScript aussieht.
Wahrscheinlich geht das nur sinnvoll
mit schnellem manuellen Review,
aber dafür ist NPM zu viel los.
Twitter, die Algorithmus...
Du meinst das auf GitHub?
Okay, GitHub.
194 Issues.
In was ist denn eigentlich
der Twitter-Algorithmus Scala?
JavaShit.
Funktionaler...
Funktionaler JavaShit mit ganz viel Klammern.
Issues.
Alles klar.
Dafür mache ich GitHub auf.
Warum spammen die Leute?
Warum spammen die Leute denn hier wie verrückt rum?
Alter, die drehen ja komplett am Rad.
Warum gibt es da ein Issue,
wo einer seine Katze postet?
Und die Frage ist jetzt natürlich,
Leute, ist es ein echtes Bild von seiner Katze
oder ein AI-generated Bild von seiner Katze?
Ich persönlich würde vielleicht fast darauf tippen,
dass es ein echtes Bild ist,
aber es könnte auch genauso gut
ein AI-generiertes Bild von seiner Katze sein.
Warum ist das eigentlich ein neues Issue
auf dem Twitter-Github-Account?
Jetzt posten sie ihre Katzenbilder, Mann.
Und am Ende wurde das Ganze geschlossen.
Moment, die Leute interessieren sich nicht dafür,
ob das geclosed wurde.
Hier, closed is.
Twitter hat es geclosed.
Das ist denen aber egal.
Die posten weiter.
Okay, was auch immer da los ist.
Und warum gehen die da so ab drauf?
Man weiß es nicht.
Stimmt, wie viele Sterne hat das Ding eigentlich?
33.000.
Ja, der hätte eigentlich trending sein müssen.
Keine Ahnung.
Was ist, was ist Starlark?
Was ist zum Teufel?
Starlark.
Language.
Was?
Starlark. What?
Sieht ein bisschen aus wie Python.
Nur ist es anscheinend nicht.
Hä?
Aber warum?
Weshalb?
Ich will es gar nicht wissen.
Einfach, ich mache einfach dicht.
Moin.
Ansonsten, ich glaube, es war nichts Spannendes die Woche sonst.
Außer, dass ich gekündigt habe.
Also, stimmt ja gar nicht.
Gekündigt habe ich im Dezember.
Dass ich jetzt dort raus bin.
Ich muss mal.
Leute, ich gucke mal was.
Ob sie mich schon gesperrt haben.
Wo ist denn mein Handy?
Ich gucke mal, ob sie mich noch gesperrt haben oder ob ich mich noch einloggen kann.
Lull.
Mal schauen.
Wartet mal.
Mal kurz Teams öffnen.
Okay, Teams kann ich mich noch einloggen.
Kein Problem.
Easy.
Ja, ich gehe davon aus, die werden mich auch erst nächste Woche sperren.
Beziehungsweise den Account deaktivieren.
Weil am Wochenende macht das ja keiner.
Warum programmiert man eigentlich einen Vorschlag-Algorithmus in Scala?
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Wahrscheinlich, weil es super krasse High-IQ-funktionaler Shit ist und sich Twitter gedacht hat.
Best ever.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Da bin ich mir nicht sicher, was das ist.
Ist das das mit den Bildern, die man wiederherstellen kann?
Oder ist es wieder was anderes?
Ne, war ich nicht.
Ich muss ehrlich sagen, ich bin erschrocken, dass sowas überhaupt jahrelang unbemerkt drin ist.
Also, man konnte ja mit.
Also Screenshots.
Ne, nicht Screenshots.
Bilder, die mit dem Standard-Android-Bildbearbeitungs-Foto-Tool bearbeitet wurden.
Und das Windows-Snipping-Tool hatte ja wohl auch irgendwelche Probleme.
Konnte man teilweise Bilder wiederherstellen, wo Sachen ausgeschwärzt wurden und so.
Richtig bescheuert, dass das überhaupt so lange drin ist und keiner gemerkt hat.
Das betrifft wahrscheinlich tausende Millionen Bilder im Internet, wo man geschwärzte Sachen wiederherstellen kann.
Zum Glück habe ich das Problem nicht.
Ich verwende die genannten Tools alle nicht.
Aber was man daran wieder schön sieht, ist, man kann sich da halt auf die ganzen Versprechen nicht verlassen.
Weil die gleichen Leute, die da dran rumwurschteln, wurschteln auch an anderer Software rum.
Und die erzählen dir zwar immer, dass das alles super Privacy und highly secure und sonst was ist.
Aber ist es in der Regel nur, weil man nicht weiß, wie es funktioniert.
Wenn du wüsstest, wie es funktioniert, ist wahrscheinlich schon alles gar nicht mehr so toll.
Geht bestimmt der Scala...
Ne, das glaube ich nicht.
Dafür ist Scala zu eklig zu programmieren.
Ich denke, der Rust-Hype wird weitergehen.
Weil Blazingly Fast written in Rust und so, ne?
Und nur Rust...
Wir wissen ja, nur Rust-Programme sind Blazingly Fast.
Alle Kustentiere freuen sich.
So.
Oder einfach irgendein x-beliebig anderes Programm nehmen.
Paint.
Zum Beispiel.
Und fertig.
Und wenn man die Sachen auf Twitter gepostet hat, ist man glücklicherweise safe.
Weil Twitter die Bilder nochmal re-encoded.
Ja, Rust ist für manche Anwendungszwecke schon nice.
Was ich nicht ganz verstehe ist, warum Leute so 0815 Sachen in Rust neu programmieren.
Ich meine, gut, weil sie es cool finden, ja.
Und weil es Rust und Blazingly Fast und so...
Aber ich finde jetzt, Rust ist nicht die Sprache, wo man jetzt die super hohe...
Ja...
Den Programmiererkomfort und Programmiergeschwindigkeit hat.
Der große Vorteil von Rust ist, halbwegs memory-safe unmanaged.
So, da wo man das braucht, ist das nice.
Dort wo man das nicht braucht, ist man wahrscheinlich besser mit was anderem.
Aber es schadet.
Es schadet auf jeden Fall auch nicht.
So.
Alter, ich hab viel zu viele Tabs auf, Mann.
Viel zu viele Tabs.
Ich blick nicht mehr durch.
Guckt euch das mal an hier.
Blub.
Jetzt geht es weiter.
Zack.
Und ich habe heute Morgen schon welche zugemacht.
Chat-GPT mit WhatsApp-Connect.
Oh, nee.
Please.
Nicht.
Nicht noch mehr AI-Spam.
Sowohl Video-Spam, als auch AI-Output-Spam.
Ich bin froh, dass sie das auf Stackoverflow erstmal untersagt haben.
Weil eine Frage einfach in Chat-GPT reinpasten kann der Fragesteller auch.
Das muss nicht irgendein Typ machen.
Oder auf Reddit.
Auf Reddit nervt mich das auch, wenn die Leute AI-Antworten posten und sowas.
Vier-Tage-Wochen.
Mehr Freizeit mit neuem Arbeitszeitmodell.
Ja, beste Vier-Tage-Woche.
Jetzt nur die Frage, ob Vier-Tage-Woche mit reduzierter Arbeitszeit oder Vier-Tage-Woche
mit zwei Stunden am Tag mehr arbeiten.
Ich persönlich finde es ja am besten Vier-Tage-Woche mit reduzierter Arbeitszeit.
Dann hat man nämlich wirklich mehr Zeit und muss nicht bis 20 Uhr oder so auf der Arbeit
rumhocken, je nachdem wann man anfängt.
Was ja auch bescheuert ist, weil die Zeit macht eh keiner.
Ja, was?
So lang.
Du bist vielleicht zwei Stunden am Tag wirklich produktiv.
Auch wenn sich das irgendwelche anderen Leute vielleicht nicht vorstellen können.
Aber gerade was, wo man sich wirklich konzentrieren muss, das kriegst du zwei Stunden am Tag hin,
dann ist gut.
Die restlichen Sachen kannst du dich um andere Dinge kümmern.
Aber mehr als komplett richtig konzentriert zwei Stunden zusammen über den Tag ist bei
den meisten Leuten nicht.
Das ist schön, wenn das geklappt hat bei dir.
Im September.
Ist ja gar nicht mehr so lang.
So lang.
Ist noch ein halbes Jahr ungefähr.
Dann bist du auch bald Informatikor.
Rainy.
Dann hast du drei Jahre vor dir, aber das kriegst du easy hin.
Lass dich bloß nicht jebaiten von der IHK, dass sie dir sagen, wie bei mir am letzten
Tag.
Sie sind durchgefallen bei der Prüfung, obwohl die Prüfung noch gar nicht gewesen
ist.
Arch Linux Speedrun.
Ganz wichtig.
Okay, lass mal gucken.
Lass mal gucken.
Was können wir uns denn anschauen?
Steckdosenleisten.
Die Lampen verschwenden mehr Strom, als du denkst.
Okay, das mag sein, weil ich habe bisher noch gar nichts darüber gedacht.
Ich hätte aber nicht gedacht, dass die sonderlich viel verbrauchen.
Was wird denn so eine Lampe verbrauchen?
Wenn es hoch kommt, zwei, drei Watt, oder?
Leistung.
Was brauchen das?
Das dürfte eigentlich viel zu viel sein für so ein kleines Funsellicht.
Na gut.
Es sei denn, es sei denn, genau, es sei denn, die Dinger werden warm und machen nicht Licht,
dann kann es natürlich noch mehr verbrauchen.
Weil sie Müll verbaut haben.
Okay, 3 Minuten 26, das gucken wir uns jetzt mal an.
Solche schaltbaren Steckdosenleisten verbrauchen still und heimlich mehr Strom, als man auf
den ersten Blick denkt.
Und zwar durch die Kontrolllampe.
Warum wackelt denn das so?
Meistens nicht um eine LED, sondern um eine herkömmliche Glimmlampe.
Ach, deswegen wackelt die so.
Und was das in Euro bedeutet, will ich in diesem Video herausfinden.
Bitte nicht von dem Flimmern irritieren lassen, hier ist nichts kaputt, das Flackern der Kontrolllampe
ist möglich die Videoaufnahme zu sehen.
Ich habe hier hinter dem Regal eine schaltbare Steckdosenleiste liegen.
Ich habe auch jede Menge schaltbare Steckdosenleisten, das sind aber China-Chinesen-Steckdosenleisten,
die man remote übers Netzwerk schalten kann.
Die haben keine LED, aber die haben einen ESP32 drin, der wahrscheinlich auch viel Strom
verbraucht.
Also gemessen hier dran.
Also so, so, so, keine Ahnung.
Wir brauchen einen ESP32, wenn er idle ist.
100, 100 Milliampere bei 5 Volt.
Ja, nicht so viel.
Liegt dort schon ein bisschen länger.
Nicht viel.
5x0,1.
Und zwar ohne, dass er zwischendurch ausgeschaltet wird.
Hier hätte eine normale, also nicht schaltbare Steckdosenleiste.
0,5 Watt, brauchen wir einen ESP32 idle.
Eine Leiste ohne Kontrollleuchte, völlig ausgereicht.
Als ich sie damals angeschlossen habe, hatte ich jedoch nur diesen Griff bereit gehabt.
Mittlerweile habe ich aber das ungute Gefühl, dass durch die ständig leuchtende Kontrolllampe
unnötig Strom verschwendet wird.
Häufig glaubt man Dinge erst, wenn man sie selbst gesehen oder gemessen hat.
Deshalb will ich das jetzt einmal nachmessen, um für mich Klarheit zu haben.
Und wie viel ist es?
Dafür könnte man auf die Idee kommen, so ein Strommessgerät zu verwenden.
Zum Beispiel?
Das funktioniert bei diesem einfachen Gerät so aber nicht.
Es zeigt 0 Watt an, da die Leistung der Glimmlampe zu gering ist.
Wenn wir auf die unsinnige Idee kommen würden, mehrere Steckdosenleisten,
hintereinander zu schalten, dann erreicht man irgendwann den Arbeitsbereich vom Messgerät,
sodass hier in diesem Fall 0,7 Watt angezeigt werden.
Das müssen wir mal ausprobieren.
Also ich habe hier ja auch so ein Ding, ein Energy, ich finde es gerade gar nicht,
Energy Master oder irgendwie sowas, da habe ich drei Stück von,
weil die sind immer praktisch, mal um auf die Schnelle was nachzugucken.
Zeig mal deine Leiste.
Ich kann dir die Leiste zeigen, die ich zum Größteil im Einsatz habe.
Energy Jam programmieren, ja.
Zum Größten Teil habe ich die, wie gesagt, ich zeig dir jetzt eine baugleiche,
weil ich weiß, dass die das Hammer immer noch welche hat davon.
Die hier.
Wobei ich nicht wirklich exakt die unter diesem Namen gekauft habe.
Das ist eine China-Chinesen-Steckdosenleiste, die gibt es in tausend verschiedenen Ausführungen.
Das ist die, die habe ich zum größten Teil im Einsatz,
weil,
man die lange Zeit flashen konnte mit Custom-Firmware.
Ich würde nicht empfehlen, die zu kaufen, wenn man sie mit Stock-Firmware betreiben möchte.
Und mit Custom-Firmware ist die Frage, ob es immer noch geht.
Da muss man immer mal hier ein bisschen schauen in den Bewertungen,
ob da Leute was von Tasmota schreiben.
Wie?
Tasmota wird nicht nachgefragt hier drinne?
Wundert mich jetzt.
Früher waren da tatsächlich Fragen zu Tasmota drin, haben die das rausgelöscht?
Oder so?
Kann man eine Comments-Sache entfernen?
Da ist doch, da steht es doch.
Warum findet Amazon nicht Tasmota, wenn ich danach suche?
Da steht es doch ganz fett, Mann.
Ah, jetzt geht's.
Ja.
Also die konnte man auch noch OTA flashen, lange Zeit.
Dann ist das cool, wenn das geht, wenn das immer noch geht.
Und das kann man wirklich empfehlen.
Also, ups.
Nein, nein, nein.
Kann wirklich empfehlen, aber nur, wenn Custom-Firmware noch geht.
Weil dann hat man übers WLAN lokal, ohne China-Chinesen-Cloud
und komische China-Chinesen-App auf dem Smartphone,
dann kann man lokal übers WLAN die Steckdosenleiste steuern.
Alle vier normalen Stecker und auch hier alle zusammen USB-Stecker.
Ja, und kann die auch über ein Webinterface steuern,
was direkt auf der Steckdosenleiste drauf ist.
Oder per MQTT oder Tasmota-Integration und alles mögliche in seine Heimautomatisierung integrieren.
Ja, davon habe ich relativ viele im Einsatz.
Bestimmt sieben, acht Stück im ganzen Haus.
Wobei, das ist nicht gelogen.
Ich habe die nicht alle im Einsatz.
Ich habe auch noch ein paar Reserve.
Also ich habe insgesamt so sieben, acht Stück.
Im Einsatz habe ich hier eine liegen, daneben eine liegen, im Wohnzimmer eine liegen, im Keller eine liegen.
Also vier Stück, die mir jetzt spontan einfallen.
Könnte durchaus sein, dass es noch mehr sind.
Ja, so, jetzt gucken wir erst mal, was hier jetzt rauskommt.
Wie viel, wie viel die Dinger denn verbrauchen.
Sinnvoll ist das so aber nicht.
Dieser Zwischenstecker ist...
Ah, Chat, Moment, muss ich gleich was zu sagen.
In dem Unternehmen wird viel mit C-Sharp gemacht.
Hat jemand Tipps zum Lernen? Möchten Sie mich gerne vorbereiten?
Ja, meine Programmier-Streams angucken, wo wir C-Sharp programmieren.
Ne, ansonsten, hast du schon C-Sharp Basic-Erfahrung?
Wenn nicht, kann ich dir immer noch empfehlen,
auch Jahre später noch, wenn du ein Buch auf Deutsch suchst,
nimm das Galileo Open Book.
Das ist zwar von 2012, aber die Basics hier,
so die ersten 16 Kapitel, die kann man dir immer noch geben.
Die sind immer noch nicht verkehrt, so rein für die Basics.
Da hast du nämlich ein Buch auf Deutsch, was gut geschrieben ist.
Ansonsten würde ich mir zu Themen, die dich interessieren, halt YouTube-Videos angucken,
Beispiele durchlesen und was auch immer.
Beispiele durchlesen und was andere Leute programmiert haben.
Aber C-Sharp ist eine gute Sprache.
Wenn du das lernst, kannst du die theoretisch von Anfang bis Ende benutzen.
Also du kannst damit alles machen, nahezu, nahezu alles.
Ich sag jetzt mal alles.
Du kannst damit alles machen, fast alle Anwendungsbereiche abgedeckt,
außer vielleicht Microcontroller-Programmierung.
Das geht damit nicht gescheit.
Wobei es da auch schon Microframework, es gibt Ansätze,
aber würde ich sagen, die sind noch nicht so gut, dass man die breit empfehlen kann.
Und du kannst sie auch jahrelang benutzen, weil da steckt Microsoft dahinter,
und es sieht nicht so aus, als geht das irgendwann demnächst wieder weg.
Webseiten gehen ja auch mit .NET mittlerweile, mit Blazor,
wobei ich Blazor nicht mag.
Ich finde das ist, so wie es jetzt aktuell ist, ziemlich unsinnig.
Für normale Webseiten.
Für irgendwelche internen Sachen, wo Suchmaschinen nicht crawlen müssen
und die auch keine Probleme damit haben,
wenn es mal ein paar Sekunden dauert, bis die Seite aufgeht, dann ist es okay.
Für Public-Webseiten in Blazor würde ich eher Abstand nehmen.
Jetzt gucken wir uns das mal fertig an.
... etwas besser und kann auch einen niedrigeren Stromverbrauch messen.
An ein Profi-Gerät kommt der natürlich nicht ran.
Aber vielleicht bekehrt mich das Ergebnis bereits ohne...
Ist das ein Shelly-Stecker?
... auf den letzten Milliwatt genau zu messen.
Die Leistung kann bei dem Zwischenstecker über das Smartphone ausgelesen werden.
Ich blende das rechts ein.
Hier sehen wir jetzt bei eingeschalteter Steckdosenleiste einen Verbrauch von 0,3 Watt.
Ich habe vorsichtshalber nochmal ein paar mehr Steckdosenleisten gemessen.
Auch hier komme ich auf ähnliche Ergebnisse.
0,2 Watt bei dieser Dreifachsteckerleiste
und bei diesem Zwischenstecker ebenfalls.
Ja gut, es ist halt ein Licht und es wird ein bisschen warm.
Das ist ungefähr so viel, wie ein ESP32 in meiner smarten Steckdosenleiste permanent verbraucht.
Ungefähr. Der ESP ist ein bisschen sparsamer.
Gerade wenn er nichts per WLAN überträgt, verbraucht er auch unter 120 mA.
0,2 Watt.
Bei dieser Mehrfachsteckdose habe ich sogar 0,5 Watt gemessen.
Das liegt daran, dass hier zwei Glimmlampen verbaut sind.
Eine für den Schalter und eine zusätzliche für die Anzeige des Überspannungsschutzes.
Was bedeutet das jetzt finanziell aufs Jahr gerechnet bei nur einer Steckdosenleiste?
Wenn wir mit den zuerst gemessenen 0,3 Watt rechnen, kommen wir auf 2,62 kWh pro Jahr.
Bei meinem Stromanbiet...
Ja gut, weil die halt 24,7 an sind.
...hinter zahle ich aktuell 49 Cent pro Kilowattstunde.
Das macht dann 1,28 Euro pro Jahr.
Also 1,30 Euro pro Steckdosenleiste.
Je nachdem, wann man viele Steckdosenleisten hat, kommen da ein paar Euro zusammen.
Aber es hält sich immer noch ganz arg in Grenzen.
Dafür, dass die Kontrolllampe hinter dem Regal leuchtet.
Nun könnte...
Naja, schockt Emoji. Ich weiß ja nicht.
Also, es ist jetzt ja nicht, dass man davon arm wird.
Man kann auch etwas konservativer rechnen.
Und sagen, es gibt die Strompreisbremse.
Die Kilowattstunde kostet also nur 40 Cent.
Zumindest für 80 Prozent von unserem Stromverbrauch.
Und wenn wir davon ausgehen, dass die Glimmlampe vielleicht nur 0,2 Watt statt 0,3 Watt verbraucht,
dann kommen wir auf 1,75 Kilowattstunden.
Oder 70 Cent pro Jahr.
Wenn wir schaltbare Steckdosenleisten...
Also das finde ich jetzt nicht so schlimm, wenn ich ehrlich bin.
...Dosenleisten dafür verwenden, wofür sie gedacht sind,
nämlich, dass sie auch mal ausgeschaltet werden,
dann leuchtet die Glimmlampe natürlich auch nicht 365 Tage lang im Jahr durchgehend.
Also...
Ja, es ist vielleicht mehr, als ich denke,
aber es ist immer noch im Verhältnis nicht so, dass man sich jetzt Sorgen machen müsste.
Ja, das hätten wir uns auch sparen können.
So, was können wir uns denn als nächstes angucken?
Lass mal hier kurz dicht machen.
Also, was haben wir denn hier?
Twenty insanely...
Nicht einfach nur helpfull, sondern insanely helpfull.
Smart Home Ideas vs. Smart Home Ideas.
Smart Home Ideas vs. Steam Deck.
Okay.
Äh, nicht Steam Deck.
Stream Deck.
Das ist ja auch nur ein Buchstabeunterschied.
Tja, das können wir uns angucken.
Es ist nur neun Minuten.
Die Sache ist bloß, ich habe kein Stream Deck.
Das heißt, ich kann damit nichts automaten.
Ich brauche auch kein Stream Deck, zumindest für Emotes,
weil ich habe ja mein eigenes Overlay gebaut für Emote-Anzeige,
wo ich die Emote selber sehe.
Was ich eigentlich auch irgendwann mal ordentlich machen müsste und fertig,
das ist eine Software, die ist zusammengefrickelt,
vor über vier Jahren oder so.
Aber, hey, ich meine, die funktioniert immer noch ganz gut, oder?
Ach.
Also, das können wir uns jetzt mal angucken.
Lass mal hier schauen.
Insanely helpfull.
Okay, komm, wir gucken uns das jetzt an.
Wir gucken.
Lass uns mal angucken, was insanely helpfull Home Automation ist mit einem Stream Deck.
The Stream Deck is one of my favorite new Smart Home devices.
Von dem Kerl ist alles immer sein favorite.
I never even knew I need it.
Because this displays and controls my Smart Home way better than I could have imagined.
The Stream Deck is a bunch of customizable buttons
that kind of have a nice tactile feel to it.
Ja, okay.
And normally video game streamers use this.
But one of you reached out to me and told me how you were trying to use one of these
as a Smart Home Dashboard.
Ja, na klar. Ich meine, es ist doch logisch, dass das funktioniert.
Du kannst customizen, was da drauf ist.
Dann kannst du damit auch theoretisch deine Garage auf und zu machen,
wenn da ein Motor drin ist und die in deine Heimautomatisierung eingebunden ist.
Ich meine, das ist ein Button.
Ein Button wie ein WiFi, ein ZigBee, ein sonstwas Button, den man integrieren kann.
Warum sollte das nicht funktionieren?
Love that idea, so I bought one right away.
The buttons have a little LCD screen behind it
and they can change based on different views or what program you're using.
But there's a problem.
Ja, es muss am Kabel angeschlossen sein, an irgendeinem PC.
Das ist wahrscheinlich das Problem.
This is a good problem.
These come with infinite possibilities.
Achso, nee. Ja gut, weil es muss halt an einem PC angeschlossen sein und an.
Oder gibt es mittlerweile schon Steam Decks, die direkt WLAN-fähig sind,
ohne am PC angeschlossen zu sein?
The buttons can do anything you can think of, which is kind of overwhelming.
That's why I'm going to show you 20 ideas on how I'm using it.
And these aren't gimmicky ideas, but actually useful.
You might be like, come on.
Mir gefällt sein T-Shirt. Poggers Half-Life.
I got a perfectly good keyboard.
With lots of buttons on it.
So eins brauche ich auch.
Irgendwie habe ich da... Half-Life.
Half-Life T-Shirt.
Das ist jetzt schon ziemlich simpel.
Brauche auch ein Half-Life T-Shirt.
Ja.
Nice.
Sowas, sowas brauche ich auch.
Rise and shine, Mr. Freeman.
Half-Life 3 T-Shirt.
Ah ja.
Exzellentes Half-Life Franchise, oder?
Half-Life Merchandise.
Half-Life 2 T-Shirt.
Okay, die gibt es noch.
Aber ich will das Original haben.
Half-Life 3 T-Shirt, da müsste es dann nackig rumlaufen.
Das hat was.
Gibt es da vielleicht auch was in Deutsch?
Ja, muss ich mal nachher gucken.
Also dann erklär uns mal.
Dann erklär mal, was man für tolle Sachen mit dem Stream Deck machen kann.
True, but...
True, lol.
Ja, Moment, das ist ja alles... Spotify juckt mich nicht.
Switch.
Okay, I don't want my family to think I'm ignoring them.
So I have a button on the Stream Deck that turns on a smart light in the hallway to let my family know I'm busy.
Using a Stream Deck for this is awesome, because I can see...
Das ist in der Tat eine ganz gute Idee, wenn man seine Ruhe haben will.
...if the switch is on or off.
Da kann man ein Licht anmachen, so nach dem Motto, nicht stören.
Quasi wie wenn man in Discord oder in irgendeinem Messenger sich auf Do Not Disturb stellt, könnte man da so ein Licht anzeigen lassen.
Achtung, der Papa ist gerade am YouTube-Video aufnehmen, nicht stören.
Wobei, dann wird erst recht gestört, wahrscheinlich.
...buy an extra smart button for this to work.
Now, if my kids ignore that red light, I have some really cool automations that happen.
So hit that subscribe button to see how I fight back.
Mit der Familie reden? Wer macht denn sowas?
Another thing that's really useful is setting buttons to quickly open up URLs in a browser.
It's actually a lot faster than opening up a browser in a browser.
Was? Nee, nee, nee, nee. Also Browser Shortcuts brauche ich nicht drauf.
Da kann ich ja oben drauf klicken oder in Bookmark Manager gucken und sowas.
Ich habe jetzt tatsächlich angefangen, ihr wisst, ich bin überhaupt gar kein Freund von irgendwelchen ausufernden Cloud-Services,
aber ich habe jetzt tatsächlich angefangen, ein paar Sachen in meinem Smartphone an Links zu speichern in Pocket,
weil das FreeTier ganz gut ist.
Und die keine großartigen Daten von mir haben wollen.
Und ich es ganz praktisch finde, manche Sachen, es ist öfters mal so, dass ich irgendwelche Links finde auf Reddit unterwegs im Zug und so,
wo ich mir denke, ey, das müsstest du dir später nochmal angucken.
Beispielsweise ich finde irgendein cooles Github-Projekt, das will ich mir merken.
Allerdings so, dass ich es später auch finde, die ganze Zeit habe ich das immer direkt in meine Notiz-App,
in meine Notiz-App eingefügt.
Das ging ja, bei Apple kannst du einfach sagen, öffnen mit Notiz-App, dann konntest du das einfügen.
Das war dann aber nur der Link, ohne jegliche Beschreibung und sonst was.
Deswegen habe ich mir jetzt mal Pocket angeguckt und bis jetzt finde ich es ganz praktisch.
Es ist vor allem auch sinnvoll, weil du zumindest Titel und Link durchsuchen kannst, ohne Premium zu haben
und vielleicht auch mal Sachen wieder findest.
Ja, das ist durchaus möglich, dass sie dann hier angeguckt werden, das ist aber nicht schlimm.
Weil ich speichere mir die ja das, wenn ich sie mal suche, weil ich weiß, ich habe mal irgendwann dazu was gesehen,
dass ich sie wieder finde. Mal gucken, ob sich das bewährt.
Warum es Pocket ist? Nun ja, weil alle selbst hostet-Alternativen mir nicht zugesagt haben.
Die hatten keine gescheiten iOS-Apps oder Android-Apps, beziehungsweise ich brauche eigentlich,
bei mir brauche ich nur iOS-Apps, die hatten keine gescheiten iOS-Apps.
Oder müssten online gehostet werden, sodass man immer permanent darauf zugreifen kann über das Internet.
Das ist natürlich auch irgendwie blöd.
Ja, Next, du meinst Nextcloud Bookmarks.
Nextcloud Bookmarks kannst du schon mal nicht richtig benutzen.
Weil Nextcloud Bookmarks gibt es keine iOS-App.
Und du kannst da auch nur Sachen hinzufügen über irgendeinen Shortcut, wenn du es direkt erreichen kannst.
Ist halt auch blöd.
Und LinkedIn ist ganz cool, aber hat auch keine App, beziehungsweise synkt halt, kann nicht synken,
sondern muss direkt die Links hinzufügen.
Das heißt, ihr müsst die Instanz auch im Internet nutzen.
Alles, Joi, danke schön für den Sub.
Das ist auch eine coole Sache.
Ich habe ja aktuell zwei Fire HD 11.
Ne, was sind die großen?
Fire HD 10, glaube ich, ne?
Zwei Fire HD 10 Touch Android-Dinger mit einfach Browser-Dashboard an der Wand hängen, oben und unten.
Das ist als Dashboard aktuell ausreichend.
Okay, weiter mal gucken. Insanely useful.
Juckt mich nicht.
Der Typ hat auch 50 verschiedene Apps auf seinem Smartphone, dass das alles funktioniert.
Power-Outlet-Strip. They automatically
turn on when I walk in the room and turn off
when I'm not in the room anymore. It's convenient.
But I don't always want
them on, so I can quickly turn them
on or off from the Stream Deck.
It's extremely easy and I get the best of
both worlds.
Dafür würde ich nicht Stream Deck klicken.
Ohne Scheiß, dafür würde ich
wirklich, entweder würde ich es über das
Webinterface machen. Ja, ich würde
es wahrscheinlich über das Webinterface von Home Assistant
machen. Weil dafür war es extra
das auf dem Schreibtisch. Keine Ahnung.
... of automation and physical
buttons. What's really cool is that you can
... Ich meine, es ist ja,
Heimautomatisierung ist ja eh generell
was sehr Individuelles und wenn er das cool findet,
warum nicht?
Man könnte auch einfach per Hand die Boxen ankreuzen.
Ja, das geht auch.
Einmal von Handschalter anschalten ist ja
schon ziemlich, ziemlich cringe, oder?
... Stream Deck. I have an Ecobee Temperature
Sensor right near my desk and it displays
the room temperature right there.
With a nice little auto-generated icon.
Leute, soll ich euch mal was sagen?
Ich habe hier rechts
einfach was stehen. Da steht jetzt drauf, dass es
Ah, fuck. Ich habe
nichts gesagt. Ich sehe es von hier gar nicht. Ich habe es verrückt.
Da steht bloß drauf, dass es 9.41 Uhr ist
und normalerweise steht da unten drunter auch eine
Ah doch, 20
20,4 Grad ist es
gerade. Steht, steht da, ja.
Und ich hatte auch eine Zeit lang so einen
Ikea-Sensor für Luftqualität
mit gemoddetem
Temperatursensor drin.
Den habe ich aber mittlerweile wieder ausgeschaltet,
weil die Dinger total,
schnell verstaubt sind und schon nach einer
Woche nach Saubermachen keine richtigen
Werte mehr geliefert haben.
Also, das ist ziemlich doof
gewesen. Tainzer, danke schön für den
Zertifizierer.
Das ist praktisch.
Allerdings habe ich hier eine Fernbedienung
liegen dafür. Aber ja, das ist schon ganz,
das ist schon ganz cool, wenn man das alles
kombiniert in so einem, auf so einem
Mini-Dashboard hat.
Also, ich gette, warum ihm das gefällt.
Und, ähm,
there's also another button displaying the set
temperature and equipment running for the thermostat.
Then, when I'm all cooled off,
I can have one more button to resume the normal
thermostat schedule, which will stop
running the AC as much. I love
that you can do all that from this little
device, and I'm just...
Aber nur, wenn es am Rechner angeschlossen ist, oder?
Man kann das nicht stand-alone.
Gibt es, gibt es mittlerweile ein Steam Deck?
Äh, nicht Steam,
Stream Deck mit
WiFi? Okay.
Okay.
Wie jetzt? Die zwei Sachen widersprechen sich doch.
Die zwei Sachen
widersprechen sich doch komplett.
Der Strom, USB-Strom
wäre nicht das Problem.
Stream Deck Mobile, ja, das ist eine, das ist eine App.
It's getting started.
When I'm at the desk
trying to get work done, it can be extremely
distracting, getting lots of notifications.
Like if someone's going in and out of the
front door non-stop because they're working
on something, those continuous video
doorbell notifications can drive me
insane. So, I have a Switch,
right here on the Stream Deck to temporarily
disable the doorbell person notifications.
Die Sache ist halt die, warum ich, warum ich da
ein bisschen
unschlüssig bin, ob sowas sinnvoll ist.
Wenn man das immer neben dem PC stehen hat
und
man sowas hier steuern will, man hat ja
den PC offen, man hat ja direkt
Zugriff
auf sein
komplettes Heimautomatisierungs-
Dashboard im Browser. Also braucht
man dann wirklich noch ein Gerät mit Buttons
dafür?
Ja.
Das, was, was mir im Weg rumsteht auf dem
Beschreib-Tisch.
Also, das ist auch ihr
Mittel of Nowhere, oder?
So, mitten in der Wüste ist er hier am
Start.
Aber, aber ein, ein
Poggers Rasen. Dafür ist
bestimmt hier
mega viel
Solar-Energie am Start.
Der kann wahrscheinlich
sein ganzes Haus mehr oder weniger damit
betreiben, wenn das hier mitten in der Wüste ist.
Weil mitten in der Wüste bietet sich das an, Solar-Panels
auf dem Dach zu haben.
Das ist so ein typisches
Kokona-Haus. Da könnt ihr mir auch vorstellen,
dass sobald da irgendjemand auf seinem
Rasen rumläuft, der da nicht hingehört,
dann wird da gleich gequickscoped aus dem Fenster.
Und dann kommt die Polizei
vorbei und fragen, was ist hier passiert?
Dann sagt der, ja, der war bei mir auf dem Grundstück
und der ist nicht weg und dann hab ich ihn gequickscoped
und dann, ja, entfernt den mal.
Da ist Wüste.
Ja, ich weiß, hier ist Wüste.
Wüste.
Alles Wüste.
Am Arsch der Welt, sozusagen.
Äh.
Was ist das?
Das läuft aus.
Das ist schlecht.
Äh.
I still like to keep an eye on it just to make sure the numbers are high unless it's a really cloudy
day which is why I have the weather displayed right above it it automatically generates an
icon based on the weather and I can also display the humidity wind or whatever I want which could
be really handy depending on where you live that way if the weather is nice I can just quickly
open up the smart shades in here I have a smart button that came with the Ikea roller shades and
it works fine but you have to worry about replacing the batteries and cluttering up your
desk with it with the stream deck I have the open and closed buttons right there so I don't
need the smart button I'm using the smart shades and other smart devices in this room way more
because of how easy it is to use on the stream deck I also like how much more productive I can be with it
I created a button I can just press when I want to focus on work
it starts up an hour-long timer and puts my devices and do not disturb this has helped me so much
because
I can easily be distracted when I should be working when I see that timer ticking down it's a great reminder
that time is precious and I shouldn't waste it but I still like to see what's going on around the
house in a non-distracting way like if the garage door is open or closed a nice little icon shows
the status of the garage door that way I can quickly see if Ali just arrived home and I can
go help with groceries or something okay I think there's nothing in there that's bothering me
because the information system works for real what do I do now the device is here
in a presentem form when I have seen the
pc hatte ich gar nicht vor mir zu kaufen so was hat man sonst noch zu bieten
diese kabel nutzen wir welches kabel ist das beste ich sage einfach mal dass es
kaum ein unterschied macht welches kabel man benutzt ich weiß es sei denn für die
super krassen design fanatiker die irgendwie wollen dass die dass die die
ummantelung des kabels zu den tischbeinen zu der tischbeinfarbe passt
oder so ja dann okay vielleicht aber ansonsten macht es kaum einen
unterschied welche kabel man benutzt solange es nicht gerade billige china
chinesen kabel sind wo usb drauf steht die aber nur chargen können und keine
daten drüber drüber übertragen trotzdem mal gucken was diese kabel
benutzen oder gucken wir mal da irgendwas sinnvolles dabei ist ich
behalte mir vor etwas fort zu skippen
alle benutzen
sie doch meistens sind sie nichts besonderes sie sind vollkommen
unbemerkt im hintergrund sind kabel doch es gibt manchmal dieses eine kabel das
besser ist als alle anderen oh ja ja dass das ölbach gold kabel für
besseres audio für 800 euro was auch nicht wirklich besser ist und bei
hörtests eigentlich keiner feststellt aber man sich viel geiler fühlt das
kabel ist dein lieblings kabel diese frage habe ich mir und meinen technik
okay mein lieblings kabel
was ist mein lieblings kabel ganz kurz rum gucken also es geht ja nicht um
gerät mit kabel dran sondern um das kabel selber
ja ich weiß was mein lieblings kabel ist beziehungsweise das was ich am was
ich am öftesten oder am was für mich am praktischsten ist ich habe drei meter
lang ist lightning kabel im bad was ich verwenden kann
Um auf die Schnelle mein Handy aufzuladen, mein Tablet aufzuladen oder, also das ist lang genug, das kann ich, wenn ich auf dem Klo sitze, theoretisch einstöpseln und das könnte ich auch auf der anderen Seite, da wo ich, also gegenüberliegende Seite vom Bad, da wo ich meine Unterhose und Socken und so habe, da kann ich es auch benutzen zum Aufladen.
Ich würde sagen, das drei Meter lange Lightning-Kabel ist mein Lieblingskabel.
Ich habe es mir über Kollegen gestellt und hier ist die Antwort.
Moin, ich bin Felix und mein Lieblingskabel ist das hier, das offizielle MagSafe-Kabel von Apple.
Ah, zum Aufladen.
Ich habe es nicht gesehen, existiert es überhaupt nicht.
Es ermöglicht nämlich kabelloses Laden.
Alles, was man dafür machen muss, ist hier so ein Netzteil nehmen, dann da das Kabel einstecken.
Sofern das Endgerät das unterstützt.
Dann hier den Puck nehmen, hinten ans iPhone dran.
Und schon lädt es, vollkommen ohne Kabel.
Ah, manche leider behaupten, dass 49 Euro zu teuer dafür sind, vor allem wenn man bedenkt, dass man noch 25 Euro Netzteil hat.
Finde ich nicht.
Ja gut, das ist die Apple-Logik, weil Apple ja keine Netzteile mehr mitliefert.
Warum auch immer, das kann man ja bei einem 1400 Euro Smartphone nicht erwarten, dass da ein Netzteil drin ist.
Und Apple begründet das ja damit, dass sie die Umwelt schonen wollen.
Ja, alles klar Apple, selbstverständlich ist der Umweltschutz der einzige Grund bei euch.
Ja.
Das glaube ich euch sofort.
Ansonsten finde ich die Sache eigentlich ganz cool mit dem Kontaktlosladen.
Mein aktuelles iPhone kann es theoretisch auch, aber ich benutze es nicht.
Ich habe sogar ein Netzteil für.
Ich bräuchte bloß noch so ein MagSafe-Ding.
Ich habe sogar eine Hülle mit MagSafe-Support.
Aber ich mache es nicht, weil ich stöpsel das Kabel ein und gut ist.
Das stört mich überhaupt gar nicht, das Kabel einzustöpseln.
Aber ich sage, das ist ein fairer Preis für die original kalifornische Apple-Magie, die man hier bekommt und vor allem auch die fortgeschrittene Sicherheitstechnologie.
Denn nur mit diesem Kabel ist es möglich, von den ganzen 20 Watt aus diesem Netzteil stolze 15 Watt ins iPhone zu laden.
Warum sollte das nur damit möglich sein?
Andere Qi-Ladegeräte schaffen da nur 7,5 Watt.
Ist das ein April?
Das ist ein April-Scherzvideo, oder?
Ist das ein April-Scherzvideo?
Das liegt sicherlich nicht an Apples komischen Restriktionen, sondern einfach nur daran, dass mein Lieblingskabel das beste Kabel ist.
Hast du ein Lieblingskabel?
Das Erschreckende ist ja, es ist jetzt nicht eines von diesen USB-C-Kabeln mit integrierter Ladeanzeige.
Finde ich auch sehr cool.
Aber wenn ich mich auf eins einschießen soll.
Diese Nylon-Kugel.
Also ich habe mir letztens so ein billig China-Chinesen 140 Watt Netzteil gekauft, wo man, also nicht für einzelne Geräte, ich weiß nicht, ob das überhaupt aktuelle USB-Standard hinbekommt.
Da kannst du aber bis zu drei Geräte halbwegs schnell dran laden.
Zweimal USB-C, einmal USB-A.
Finde ich eigentlich ganz praktisch.
Roten Lightning, USB-C auf Lightning Ankerkabel.
Das sind meine, sag ich jetzt mal, Lieblingskabel.
Warum?
Weil sie sind rot und leuchten rot.
Also leuchten tun sie nicht.
Aber ich weiß halt einfach, ich bin konditioniert beim Lightning.
Ey, das ist genau das Kabel, was ich habe.
Nur in Silber.
Also nur in Grau.
Das ist das drei Meter Lightning-Kabel, was bei mir auf dem Klo hängt.
Das finde ich tatsächlich auch nice.
Das rote Kabel ist das Lightning-Kabel.
Ich will halt nicht mit Schwarz-Grau und was auch immer suchen, sondern ich weiß einfach Rot-Lightning.
Und das kann eigentlich nichts, weil Lightning kann ja sowieso nicht schnelle Datenübertragung.
Es lädt und es passt und alles ist jetzt rot.
Und da weiß ich halt einfach Apple-Gerät an Rot anschließen.
So, das war es also.
Aha, ein nices rotes Lightning-Kabel.
Ihr kennt das Problem.
Ihr habt euch ein neues Stück Equipment gekauft.
Wie in meinem Fall dieser wunderschöne mobile Scanner.
Die drehen alle schon ein bisschen am Rad, oder?
Stellt fest.
Micro-USB.
Aber wie soll das denn an meinen Laptop passen?
Fragte mein inneres Ich.
Und die Lösung war ein Adapter an einem Adapter an einem Adapter.
Oh, der gute Anker-USB-Switch.
Ein Micro-USB auf USB.
T-Kabel.
Yo Leute, ich bin Ilyas und mein...
Das ist aber schon so ein halbes, halbes April-Scherz-Video, oder?
Mein Lieblingskabel hat mir keinerlei technischen Mehrwert gebracht, seitdem ich 30 Euro dafür ausgegeben habe.
Denn ich hatte bereits ein Kabel, um mein MacBook mit dem Monitor zu verbinden, allerdings war das schwarz.
Und weil mir mein Setup im Studio wichtig war und ich eigentlich nur sehr cleane, weiße Produkte haben wollte,
musste ein Thunderbolt 3 Kabel in weiß her.
Ich hätte auch jedes andere x-beliebige Kabel wählen können, doch es musste schnell genug sein,
weswegen meine Wahl eben auf das fiel.
Mein Leben ist jetzt kein Stück besser. Obwohl das schwarze Kabel perfekt funktioniert, liegt es nur noch in der Schublade.
Ich bin 30 Euro ärmer, aber...
Ja, ist ja, ist ja auch gerechtfertigt. Ich meine, es ist ein Apple-Kabel.
Mein Designherz schlägt auch um einiges ruhiger.
Oh, und das wunderschöne Apple-Amazon-Packaging hat sicherlich nicht dazu beigetragen.
Ich bin Marc vom m1mtech-Channel und das hier ist mein aktuelles Lieblingskabel.
Warum das so ist, hat gleich mehrere Gründe.
Es ist vom Aufbau...
Anker-China-Chinesen-Zeug.
Oh ja, ein USB-C auf USB-C-Kabel mit einer Länge von 1,80 m,
was mir damit ausreichend Spielraum und mit 140 Watt auch genug Ladeleistung mit verschiedenen Geräten bietet.
Das Kabel ist dabei mit einem Nylon-Geflecht ummantelt und etwas starrer, als man es sonst von den Plastikteilen kennt.
Dadurch wirkt es aber nicht nur schön hochwertig, es ist auch extrem robust und soll sogar bis zu 80 kg Zugkraft aushalten.
Hast also auch immer gleich ein Rettungsseil dabei.
Noch besser gefallen...
Das heißt, ich...
Ich probier mich mal demnächst abzuseilen mit meinem USB-Kabel.
...fallen mir aber die Stecker, die eine Hülle aus Metall haben und hochglanzlackiert sind.
Das fühlt sich original wie Autolack an und passt auch noch farblich perfekt zu meinen Schuhen.
Wie hochwertig will ein USB-C-Kabel sein? Ja.
Boah Leute, unter all den Kabeln, die es so gibt, war für mich direkt klar, was mein absolutes Lieblingskabel ist.
Und zwar dieses Micro-USB-Kabel.
Eindeutig.
Obviously.
Leute, wie geil ist das tägliche Abenteuer, nicht genau zu wissen, ob man das Kabel jetzt richtig oder falsch herum einsteckt.
Und auf der anderen Seite ist es einfach schön, mit diesem Kabel eine Konstante im Leben zu haben.
Ich meine, egal wie hektisch der Alltag sein sollte, ich kann mich immer darauf verlassen, dass dieses Kabel, egal was passiert, mit langsamen 5 Watt mein Smartphone auflädt.
Ja nicht, dass die Batterie noch überlastet wird.
Obwohl, mein Smartphone hat gar kein Micro-USB mehr.
Ja, dann wird es Zeit für ein Micro-USB auf USB-C, würde ich sagen.
Oh ne, das Teil.
Wait a minute, das gibt es doch schon ewig nicht mehr.
Moment, das ist doch was anderes.
Ich bin Jonas und auch ich möchte euch gerne mein Lieblingskabel vorstellen.
Und das müsst ihr einfach gesehen haben.
Das hier ist es.
Und falls ihr euch jetzt denkt, das ist doch nur irgendein Kabel.
Nein.
Nein, das ist ein ganz besonderes Kabel.
Es ist mein Lieblingskabel.
Und vor allem ist es das beste und schnellste Kabel.
Und es ist das Kabel, was ich jeden Tag am meisten benutze.
Dieses Kabel ermöglicht es mir erst, dass ich mein MacBook mit meinem Pro-Display verbinden kann, was nur 5...
Ist das Pro-Display das Ding, wo der Ständer 2.000 Euro kostet?
Beziehungsweise die VESA-Halterung alleine schon 200 Euro?
... 2.500 Euro gekostet hat und keinen Standfuß im Lieferumfang hat.
Und auch der Preis von 149 Euro für dieses Kabel ist eigentlich...
Das ist ja ein Schnapper.
... wirklich geschenkt.
Und falls euch der Preis noch nicht überzeugt hat, dieses Kabel hier ist schwarz.
Und es ist ein Thunderbolt 4 Pro Kabel, also gemacht für echte Pros.
Und weil ich natürlich ein Pro bin, habe ich drei Stück davon.
Hey, ich bin Max vom Kanal Maxl und mein aktuelles Lieblings-Ladekabel möchte ich nicht mehr missen.
Es gehört nicht, wie viele wahrscheinlich von euch vermuten, zu einem Smartphone, sondern zu einer Smartwatch.
Genauer gesagt der Apple Watch Ultra.
Das Ladekabel dieser Uhr ist in so vielen Punkten einfach ein Traum.
Angefangen beim stoffummatelten Kabel an sich.
Über die hochwertige und matte Aluminiumfassung des Ladepucks bis hin zur Ladegeschwindigkeit, die für Apple Watch Verhältnisse ziemlich okay ist.
So vieles wurde hier einfach richtig gemacht.
Und gerade das Verwenden solch hochwertiger Materialien sieht man bei Ladekabeln leider viel zu selten.
Sodass sich dieses umso mehr von der Masse abhebt.
Wodurch es mir extrem schwer fällt, das Ladekabel der Apple Watch Ultra...
...gegen ein anderes aus dieser Kategorie zu tauschen.
Geschweige denn in Zukunft auf dieses verzichten zu müssen.
Als Kind hat er mich angeschrieben und gefragt, was mein Lieblingskabel sei.
Ehrlich gesagt, Leute.
Es ist ein Video vom 1. April.
Und manche sind eindeutig 1. April G-Bates.
Bei manchen bin ich mir da allerdings nicht so sicher.
Entweder wurde der Bruder gehackt oder der verarscht mich.
Aber nein, der meint das todernst.
Also, mein Lieblings-
Oh, es gibt ja auch so super hyperaktive...
...Technik-Youtuber.
Ist...
...immer schwierig anzugucken für mich.
Das Kabel ist...
...das hier.
Das 45 Euro teure Lightning zu AUX-Kabel für die AirPods Max.
Jaja, ich weiß, bitte noch nicht anspucken.
Dieses Kabel hier hat für mich einen ganz emotionalen Wert.
Ihr müsst verstehen, man kann mir nur sehr schwer ein Geschenk holen...
...da ich den Luxus besitze, alles Material zu besitzen, was ich jemals haben wollte.
Und als ich dann mit einem Kumpel darüber abgelästert habe, wie kacke Apple doch sei...
...da man um hierauf lossless, audio-latenzfrei...
...Musik hören zu können.
Dieses bescheuerte Original-Kabel brauche ich nie.
Warum braucht man ein Kabel, um lossless-Audio zu hören?
Liegt es nicht eher am...
...erst mal in welchem Format...
...die Musik vorliegt...
...und dann ob es der Decoder kann?
Also...
...ich kann auch mit einem stinknormalen Klinkestecker lossless-Audio hören.
...im Leben auf die Idee kommen würde...
...45 Euro...
...für so ein Schwachs auszugeben.
Naja, zwei Tage später kam er vorbei und meinte zu mir...
...endlich, endlich habe ich etwas gefunden, was du unbedingt haben möchtest...
...aber niemals dir selbst kaufen würdest...
...und drückte mir eine Tüte von Apple in die Hand.
Ihr könnt euch sicherlich jetzt vorstellen, was da drin war...
...und genau deswegen ist das der Grund, weshalb dieses Kabel für mich so unfassbar wichtig ist...
...und weshalb das praktisch unbezahlbar geworden ist.
Guten Tag, mein Name ist...
...aaaah, ja...
...Andreas und ich bin hier reingeraten, weil ich den YouTube-Kanal spiele...
...und Zeug rund um Technik für Zuhause...
Der Klinke-Output ist halt analog.
Soll ich dir mal ein Geheimnis verraten?
Deine Ohren sind auch analog.
Deswegen ist das bei Audio-Übertragung gar nicht mal so wild, wenn da was analog ist.
...betreibe.
Und ich habe genauso wenig ein Lieblingskabel, glaube ich, wie ich...
...einen Lieblingsfilm oder ein Lieblingslied habe.
Aktuell bin ich unterwegs und deswegen habe ich kein Beispiel für meine eigentliche Faszination...
...zur Hand.
Stromkabel, die zwar einen Standard-Adapter benutzen, aber sich irgendwie in die Gehäuseform des Gerätes integrieren.
Wie zum Beispiel die abgewinkelten Stromstecker an den alten Sonos-Boxen oder jetzt bei den neuen Homepods.
Was aber noch wichtiger ist und was ich immer dabei habe, meistens in der Hosentasche, ist dieses Kabel.
Das ist das Ladekabel von Tony Box.
Das ist kein besonders schönes oder aufwendiges oder interessantes Kabel.
Das ist eigentlich mehr oder weniger ein normaler Kabel.
Ich habe zwar Netzstecker in so einen komischen Plastikfuß gegossen, aber es ist leer gelaufene Tony Box.
Man kann damit im Zweifelsfall quengelnde Kinder ruhig stellen.
Was ist eine Tony Box?
Und ist damit jedem Kabel überlegen, egal wie viel Gigabit, Gigawatt, Gigahertz es übertragen kann.
Es ist diesen Kabeln gigantisch überlegen.
Ich habe eine Weile überlegt. Es gibt so viele tolle Kabel.
Stoff ummantelt oder in schönen Farben mit besonderen Funktionen.
Doch es gibt ein Kabel, das einen ganz besonderen Vorteil hat.
Es hat einen großen Platz in meinem Herzen.
Es lag im Lieferumfang meines Teenage Engineering OP-1 Field Synthesizers bei und sieht einfach nur großartig aus.
Es hat weiße, formschöne USB-C Anschlüsse auf beiden Seiten und dazwischen ist ein mittleres Grau.
Nirgendwo ist eine Beschriftung.
Alles ist angenehm weich gummiert und fühlt sich deswegen sehr hochwertig an.
Es ist weder besonders lang noch kurz.
Es kann im Grunde gar nichts besonderes, aber es ist schön.
Ich habe es bis heute, wenn überhaupt, fünfmal benutzt.
Das größte Problem ist, dass man es nicht einzeln kaufen kann.
Das bedeutet, dass man dieses Kabel nur bekommt, wenn man 2.000 Euro für einen Synthesizer ausgibt.
Ich hoffe, unser Video zum 1. April hat euch gefallen.
Macht's gut, bis zum nächsten Mal. Ciao.
Rare Cable.
Ich weiß nicht Bescheid.
YouTube, deine Chance, nochmal was Neues vorzuschlagen.
Nope.
Mein eigenes Video wird vorgeschlagen.
Sehr gut.
Nice.
Dann gucken wir uns jetzt das an.
Wenn man ja wieder hier drüber wächst, was Sinnvolles machen könnte, wie Videotabs muten oder so.
Das Galaxy S23 Luxus.
Die machen bestimmt wieder irgendwelchen Beschiss bei Image-Nachbearbeitung.
Da war doch schon mal was früher.
Das Galaxy S23 Luxus.
Das ist auch ultra schnell und macht ultra gute Fotos.
Was kostet das?
Zumindest gilt es als eines der besten Fotos-Smartphones.
Moment, Moment.
Was kostet das?
Wo ist dein Video zum 1. April?
Gibt's nicht.
Ich hab noch nie ein April-Chats-Video gemacht.
Werde ich auch nicht anfangen.
Ach, das ist mit Handyvertrag.
Ja, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Okay.
Das geht sogar halbwegs.
Im Vergleich zu Apple-Preisen.
Apple kostet als Shit halt einfach nochmal 400 Euro mehr mittlerweile.
Auf dem Markt.
Wenn nicht sogar als das Beste.
Bei MrWhoTheBoss gewinnt es zum Beispiel in Sachen Fotos,
gegen das iPhone 14 Pro Max.
Aber das S23 Ultra macht auch einige ziemlich komische Sachen.
Schaut mal hier.
Ich muss nach Ultra schauen.
Ultra, Ultra.
Naja.
Es ist immer noch 400 Euro billiger als das Beste.
Nicht mal das Beste als neues iPhone.
Moment, das ist wieder mit Vertrag.
Ähm.
Ah.
Okay.
Nee.
Das kostet ungefähr das gleiche wie ein teures iPhone.
Alter, sind Handys mittlerweile abfuck teuer, Mann.
Alter, Scheiß.
1600 Euro für ein Handy.
Ja, vor Instagram.
Übrigens ist es international immer sehr verwirrend, wenn man Handy sagt und denkt,
man benutzt jetzt hier so krasse Fremdworte und dabei versteht niemand auf der Welt Handy
außer in Deutschland.
Hier ein Foto-App.
Wo kommen die 10?
Hä?
Moment!
What?
Bildoptimierung in der vorinstallierten Foto-App.
Äh..
Das ist ja weh
und diese Mondfotos, die habt ihr womöglich schon gesehen.
Ja.
Das habe ich... mitbekommen.
Haha.
Das kenne ich noch, diese Geschichte mit dem, also ich kann mich da noch dunkel dran erinnern, dass da irgendwas mit dem Mond gewesen ist, weil ich mir nicht mehr sicher bin, ob Samsung war und ein Handy, aber irgendwas mit Mondfotos war tatsächlich mal in letzter Zeit.
Das ging ja neulich schon überall durchs Netz. Das krasse ist, die ging nicht mal über die interne Fotoverbesserungs-App, sondern die kam direkt so aus der Kamera. Ja, da fotografiert das Handy die Sachen, die da definitiv nicht sind.
Sind die Fotos vom S23 Ultra womöglich also ultra-fake? Wir zoomen da mal raus und gucken uns das mal genauer an.
Unter anderem haben wir die Fotos des S23 Ultra mit einer Mittelklasse-Spiegel.
Das ist eine Reflex- und einer spiegellosen High-End-Kamera verglichen. Bleibt dran.
Liebe Hackerinnen, liebe Internet-Surfer, herzlich willkommen hier bei...
Ja gut, Handy bedeutet so viel wie das ist praktisch, aber das wird nicht als Smartphone-Wort benutzt.
Dieses Video wird gesponsert von CyberGhost.
Bearbeiten von Fotos, das hat ja schon ne lange Tradition.
Und jetzt, Achtung, klingt vielleicht wie ein Witz, den Chat-GPT geschrieben hat, aber...
Was haben Instagram-Influencer und...
Josef Stalin gemeinsam.
Beide benutzen Fotofilter.
Ja klar, damals war das alles noch ein bisschen komplizierter, da musste man wirklich mit Schere und Pinsel ran.
Und Stalin hat nicht nur unliebsame Leute aus Propagandafotos rausgeschoppt,
sondern zum Beispiel auch die Hockennarben aus seinem Gesicht retuschieren lassen.
Aber, dass die ersten Bildmanipulationen gezielt für Propagandazwecke eingesetzt wurden, ist jetzt wenig überraschend.
Und diese Methoden zur Bildbearbeitung sind einfach schon 100 Jahre alt.
Und haben sich im Laufe der Zeit...
Logischerweise immer mehr verbessert.
Heute, und das ist natürlich schon ein großer Unterschied, wird die Manipulation schon bei der Aufnahme vorgenommen.
Weil die Kamera denkt, schon zu wissen, was die Fotografierenden sehen wollen.
Und wenn die Kamera sich beim Fotografieren nicht ganz sicher ist, dann bietet sie die, sagen wir mal, kreativen Bildverbesserungen zumindest nachträglich an.
Schaut mal hier, das ist einfach ein Foto in der vorinstallierten Galerie-App von Samsung, wenn man auf Bild überarbeiten tippt.
Mit den Augen stimmt jetzt aber auch irgendwas nicht, oder?
Und das ist...
Da spiegelt sich dann irgendwas drin, was gar nicht da ist.
Definitiv mehr als früher auf Handys, ein bisschen Farbkorrektur und Helligkeit und Kontrast.
Aber manchmal macht die Bildverbesserungs-KI auch ganz komische Sachen mit den Fotos.
Dem Twitter-Nutzer EarCity ist aufgefallen, dass Samsung bei manchen Bildern Dinge hinzu erfindet.
Und zwar Zähne zum Beispiel, die das sieben Monate alte Kind auf dem Foto eigentlich noch gar nicht hat.
Und das haben wir natürlich direkt auf unserem S23 Ultra testet.
Wir haben das Gerät ausprobiert und wir haben jetzt zwar nicht so ein krasses Ergebnis bekommen,
aber auch bei uns hatte die KI immer wieder Probleme und hat einem kleinen Kind einfach mal die Zunge mit unscharfen Zähnen ausgetauscht.
Vor allem aber die Augen waren Thema bei unseren Testfotos, da hat die KI immer wieder mal einen richtigen Bock geschossen.
Und auch generell einfach mal Zähne deutlich schlechter gemacht, als sie auf dem Testfoto eigentlich waren.
Ja, so einen richtig krassen Meilenstein in der Smartphone-Fotografie hat Samsung mit dem S20.
Ultra gelandet, als sie verkündet haben, dass ihre Handys jetzt den Mond besonders gut fotografieren.
Ja, da kann ich mich noch dran erinnern.
Da kann ich mich noch dran erinnern, dass das da ein bisschen rumgefakt wurde.
Dieser Hype um die Mondfotografie hat aber nicht besonders lange gehalten.
Im Januar 2021 kochten die Emotionen hoch, als Leute unter anderem der deutsche Tech-YouTuber Alexi Beksi behaupteten,
Samsung würde bei Galaxy-Telefonen Bilddetails hinzu erfinden, die gar nicht da sind.
Konkret beim Fotografieren des Vollmonds.
Das gipfelte dann in einem...
Ziemlich aufwendigen, debunking Artikel auf inverse.com, wo mit vielen Worten bewiesen wurde,
dass die Fake-Vorwürfe gar nicht stimmen könnten und dass das halt alles nur nicht super gut...
Keine, kein Fake.
Selbstverständlich macht ein Handy ohne irgendwie großem Objektiv und sonst was dran bessere Fotos als da...
Ja, ja.
...Bildverbesserungs-Algorithmen von Samsung liegen.
Als Beweis hatte der Autor mit einem teuren 200-600mm-Objektiv auf einer Sony A7R III ein Vergleichsfoto gemacht
und dann das Bild vom Handy und der torrent Sony-Kamera übereinandergelegt.
Und die Bilder stimmten generell überein, nur dass das Foto vom Handy halt deutlich schärfer war als das mit der Profi-Kamera.
Und das hätte einen ja vielleicht stutzig machen können, aber dennoch war das Resultat...
Nein, Samsung erfindet nichts neu, sondern hat halt einfach die tollsten Algorithmen.
Das haben dann etliche Websites nachgeplappert, das Thema ist durch, die Fakten haben gesprochen.
Doch nun gab es damals schon einen Reddit-Post, in dem User Moonfruit Raw demonstriert,
wie er oder sie einen geblurrten Mond vom Bildschirm abfotografiert.
Und zwar mit einem grauen Smiley drauf in einfarbigen Grau.
Ja, und am Ende ist da, wo der Smiley war, Mondtextur drin.
Und die kann die Samsung-KI-Detailverbesserungs-Engine ja nicht aus der Vorlage rausgeholt haben,
denn da war ja gar nichts, da war ja nur graue Fläche.
Und fast das gleiche Spiel haben wir jetzt mit dem neuesten S23 Ultra wiedererlebt.
Samsung zeigt, wie sie tolle Mondfotos hinkriegen, alle feiern das und etwas später kommt...
Ja, doch nicht so.
Denn auch diesmal hat jemand auf Reddit gezeigt, dass das so gar nicht stimmen kann, was Samsung uns da verspricht.
Dazu hat...
Nein, wer hätte das so denken können?
...der Nutzer iBreak-Fotos ein Foto vom Mond unscharf gemacht und ist dann nochmal mit seinem S23 Ultra abfotografiert.
Dabei ist dann dieses Foto entstanden.
Ja, und das zeigt eben ganz deutlich, dass da vor allem Samsungs KI am Werk...
Die Kamera hat einfach so weit reingezoomt in was, was nicht da ist, dass es scharf geworden ist.
Und die eigentliche Kamera mit dem Zoom, wie es Samsung suggeriert.
Das konnten wir bei unserem eigenen Test übrigens auch so bestätigen.
Samsung selbst erklärt die Mondfotofunktion so, dass die Helligkeit heruntergefahren wird,
dann mehrere Bilder übereinandergelegt werden und im letzten Schritt die KI das Rauschen entfernt
und die Details des Mondes verbessert.
Also, dass die KI die Details des Mondes verbessert, damit ist ja eigentlich alles gesagt.
Klar ist das nicht so stumpf, dass Galaxy-Handys immer, wenn sie einen Mond erkennen, ein bisschen im Flash-Speicher rumsuchen,
und dann ein Stock-Foto des Mondes dahin klatschen.
Ne, das ist schon ein bisschen mehr sophisticated.
Fakt ist aber, es werden da Sachen reingerechnet, die im Fotomotiv definitiv nicht drin sind.
Das soll jetzt hier aber auch gar kein Hate gegen diese Entwicklung in der Smartphone-Fotografie werden.
Denn Smartphones sind einfach Kameras, die man in der Hosentasche mit sich rumträgt.
Und die meisten Menschen haben vermutlich auch keinen Bock, sich so intensiv mit Fotografie und so Dingen wie
Blende, Brennweite, Weißabgleich und sowas zu beschäftigen.
Und genau für die geht es darum, dass sie...
einfach möglichst ohne groß nachzudenken ihr Smartphone nehmen und ein Foto machen, das dann am Ende gut aussieht.
Deswegen haben ja viele gemeint, das geht schon klar, was Samsung da macht mit den Mondbildern.
Ist ja nicht für Leute gedacht, die wissenschaftliche Astro-Fotografie betreiben wollen,
sondern für Leute, die gerne ihr Glas Rotwein vor dem Mond in Szene setzen möchten für Instagram.
Okay, das mit dem Weinglas klappt trotz KI nicht so richtig, das haben wir für euch ausprobiert.
Naja, aber dazu kommt ja noch, dass Kameras vor allem in Smartphones ja auch immer eine gewisse Interpretation
der Wirklichkeit liefern.
Wir haben das mal versucht und uns neben dem S23 Ultra noch ein iPhone 13, eine Mittelklasse-Spiegelreflex,
die Nikon D5300 und ein etwas mehr High-End, eine Lumix GH5 genommen.
Damit haben wir dann...
Ich hab so keinen Plan von Kameras.
...einfach mal mitten am Tag viermal das gleiche Foto gemacht.
Äh, okay.
Kann man da vielleicht noch die Auflösung ein bisschen höher stellen?
Also außer Helligkeitsunterschiede muss ich ehrlich sagen, erkenne ich jetzt hier zumindest im Video,
...nix.
Ich erkenne da keinen Unterschied.
...macht alle Kameras waren für den Test auf Vollautomatik gestellt.
Und auch hier fällt deutlich auf, dass alle Fotos anders aussehen, vor allem in Sachen Farben.
Besonders deutlich wird das, wenn wir hier mal das Foto vom Samsung-Handy neben das Bild von der Lumix legen.
Ja, wahrscheinlich post-processed Samsung das Ding.
Besonders deutlich wird das, wenn wir hier mal das Foto vom Samsung...
Ja, wahrscheinlich post-processed das Samsung einfach.
...macht irgendwie die Sättigung hoch, macht den Himmel blauer.
Und das andere ist halt mehr oder weniger halt so RAW, in guter Qualität das Bild, dass es halt dann ein Profi gut nachbearbeiten könnte.
...Handy neben das Bild von der Lumix legen.
Da ist einfach deutlich weniger Farbe drin.
Und viele Smartphones neigen dazu, Fotos zu übersättigen.
Etwas anders sieht es aus, wenn wir uns die...
Weil es wahrscheinlich auf den ersten Blick besser aussieht.
RAW-Aufnahmen der vier Testgeräte anschauen.
Hier werden die Fotos weitestgehend ohne Bearbeitung gespeichert.
Denn...
Die möchten professionelle Fotografinnen und Fotografen ja am Ende selbst machen und dann eben sagen, so oder so intensiv sollen die Farben sein.
Wenn wir jetzt einfach das RAW-Bild von der Lumix-Kamera in Photoshop machen, dann klicken wir einmal hier und schon wirkt das Bild deutlich ähnlicher zum S23.
Und trotzdem sehen die RAW-Aufnahmen der Smartphones farblich deutlich intensiver aus als von den großen Kameras.
Das macht am Ende das Bearbeiten nach dem Fotografieren auf jeden Fall komplizierter.
Aber das ist auch die gute Neuigkeit.
Man kann auf einem Handy...
Die ganze KI-Optimierung und so weiter ja immer noch ausschalten und einfach klassische manuelle Fotos machen, die man danach selbst bearbeitet.
Bei Samsung heißt das konkret Szenen-Optimierung.
Wenn man das abschaltet, dann passieren solche Dinge wie mit dem Mond nicht mehr.
Aber dafür braucht man auch, wenn man den Mond fotografieren will, halt auch schon deutlich besseres Foto-Equipment.
Also insgesamt greift Samsung schon ziemlich...
Ja, dafür macht man mit dem besseren Equipment auch wirklich ein Foto vom Mond und nicht von irgendwas geblurrtem am Himmel.
Wo dann Samsung dann auferlegt.
Ja, dafür macht man mit dem besseren Equipment auch wirklich ein Foto vom Mond und nicht von irgendwas geblurrtem am Himmel. Wo dann Samsung dann auferlegt.
drüber macht mit einem Mondbild. Tief in die Trickkiste und generiert zum Beispiel beim Mond
Bildanteile, die nicht in der Vorlage sind. Und als Resultat fragt sich gerade die Techwelt,
was ist eigentlich ein Foto? Wo zieht man die Grenze? Ich meine, die Übergänge zwischen
KI-optimiertem Bild und KI-generiertem Bild à la State of Fusion sind ja irgendwie auch fließend.
Hier dieses Bild vom Papst, das habt ihr vielleicht schon gesehen. Und obwohl ich mich beruflich mit
KI-Bildgenerierungstools beschäftige, habe ich nicht gecheckt, dass das Foto generiert ist,
weil ja auch die Mode im Vatikan ja schon manchmal ein bisschen besonders ist. Naja,
aber wenn mein Handy meinem Bild, mit dem ich meine Realität aufgenommen habe,
als Optimierung jetzt ungefragt eine leiste Zähne verpasst, dann ist das auf jeden Fall
ein ernsthafter Einschnitt in die Wirklichkeit, die ich so vielleicht gar nicht möchte. Auf der
anderen Seite finde ich das natürlich super, wenn mein Handy mein Sonnenuntergangsfoto so
aussehen lässt, als wäre ich ein Profi. Zumindest, was da auf jeden Fall merkwürdig
dran ist.
Stell dir mal vor, wie verwirrend das sein kann. Du machst ein Bild, du denkst dir, ach
gut, gut, dass ich mich, damit ich mich dann dran erinnere oder dass ich nochmal nachgucken
kann. Ich mach mal schnell ein Foto von, machst ein Foto von, speicherst es und sagst dann,
ah, wie war das nochmal? Ah, zum Glück habe ich ein Foto gemacht. Und du guckst dann in
das Bild rein und das Bild zeigt in Details was anderes, wie du es im Kopf hast. Dann
zweifelst du selbst an deinem Hirn. Da denkst du dir, was, der konnte doch damals noch gar
keine Zähne.
Zähne haben, aber auf meinem Foto sieht man doch ganz klar, der hat Zähne gehabt.
Da denkst du, hä?
Das ist ein eller Fotograf und meine Realität eben so abbildet, wie ich sie wahrnehme. Auch
wenn sie in Wahrheit vielleicht etwas weniger spektakulär aussieht, als in meinem Kopf.
Bei Fotos von Menschen ist das aber eine andere Sache. Was macht das eigentlich mit uns, wenn
wir Menschen nur noch in der optimierten Version sehen und wir danach in den Spiegel gucken?
Wie seht ihr das? Ist das eine gute Entwicklung mit der KI?
Seitdem ich meinen neuen Rasierer habe, gucke ich gerne in den Spiegel.
Gibt es Optimierungen oder eher gefährlich? Schreibt es gerne in die Kommentare und gerne
auch abonnieren natürlich. Tschüss.
See you.
Das ist wie bei den... Ja, das ist was ähnliches. Nur da gab es ja richtige Probleme, auch rechtliche,
wo es dann zu Verwirrung gekommen ist. Es gibt ja eine Einstellung, nur dass die meisten
Leute die wahrscheinlich nicht benutzen werden. Das ist defaultmäßig an, weil die Bilder
besser...
In Anführungsstrichen besser aussehen und die Leute halt standardmäßig draufdrücken
wollen und ein hübsches Bild haben wollen. Ich verstehe schon, warum die Hersteller das
standardmäßig einschalten. So, was haben wir denn sonst noch? Ja, das stimmt. Bei Szenenoptimierung
denkt jetzt auch jemand, der das einfach nur liest, nicht dran, dass es sich da eigentlich
um eine AI handelt, die Bildinhalte dazu erfindet. Das solltest du vermeiden in deinem Smart Home.
Okay. Hat nicht viele Views. Mal gucken, ob da was dabei ist, was ich vermeiden sollte.
Oder? Ja, dann bin ich mal gespannt, was wir vermeiden sollen.
Also, was man definitiv in seinem Smart Home vermeiden sollte, das kann ich euch jetzt an
der Stelle mal sagen, ist irgendwelches proprietäres China-Chinesen-Zeug, was nur mit offizieller
China-Chinesen-App über offizielle China-Chinesen-Cloud-Server funktioniert. Das sollte man vermeiden.
Und generell zu viel Cloud-gestütztes Zeug bei essentiellen Sachen. Zum Beispiel, wenn das Internet nicht geht,
kann ich meine Heizung nicht mehr richtig einstellen. Also, das muss nicht sein.
Und auch ein Fehler, zumindest meiner Meinung nach, den viele am Anfang machen, zu viel RGB-Beleuchtung,
weil in vielen Fällen braucht es überhaupt keine RGB-Beleuchtung und man ist mit einem dimmbaren
Licht oder im Zweifelsfall dimmbar plus Farbtemperaturanpassung besser bedient als mit
einer vollständigen RGB-Lampe. Okay, zeigt mal her. Äh, hallo? Mein Browser ist verreckt. Okay.
GG Eats. Mach mal neu auf. Moin moin und hallo bei Schlauchern.
Jetzt ist die Musik zu laut. Warum? Weil YouTube sich das nicht merkt. Okay, jetzt funktioniert es wieder.
Was auch immer das wieder gewesen ist. Einfach... Einfach Browser kaputt gegangen. Nice.
Hatte ich übrigens unter Linux noch nie, dass einfach mein Browser kaputt geht.
Ich bin Marcel und heute sage ich dir, welche Fehler du in deinem Smart Home vermeiden solltest...
Boah, das ist leise.
...und welche Fehler du in deinem Smart Home vermeiden solltest...
...und welche ich gemacht habe, damit du sie nicht mehr machen musst.
Okay, auf geht's.
Los geht's.
Auf YouTube wirst du sicherlich schon einige Videos gesehen haben, was alles mit Smart Home möglich ist.
Und auch ich habe dir schon ein paar Sachen gezeigt, die ich gemacht habe.
Ja. Gut.
Wovon aber nicht so viele Leute sprechen, sind die Fehler, die wir alle begangen haben.
Und um dich dafür zu schützen, habe ich mal eine kleine Liste gemacht und die gehen wir jetzt...
Ja, Fehler. Ich meine, solange man was daraus lernt, ist ja gut. Im Endeffekt habe ich auch schon einige Geräte hier hingestellt,
die sich dann als nicht so sinnvoll herausgestellt haben. Ja, ist so.
...stück für Stück ab. Und fangen wir hier doch mit dem Thema WLAN an.
WLAN.
Vermeide WLAN.
Du wirst sicherlich wie ich die meisten Geräte über WLAN...
Ja, gut.
...manchmal, weil es nicht anders geht, manchmal, weil man faul ist und manchmal geht es halt einfach nicht anders.
Richtig. Genau.
...einem Handy beispielsweise.
Das Problem hierbei ist nur, dass all diese Geräte mit Bandbreite gefüttert werden sollen.
Und wenn man sich dann noch dazu entscheidet, smarte Geräte, die über WLAN laufen, einzubinden, wird es nicht besser.
Inzwischen habe ich...
Die meisten Geräte machen jetzt ja nicht so den Mega-Traffic und wenn man ein paar ordentliche Access-Points im Haus verteilt hat,
kann man schon das 0815-Smart-Home-Zeug über WLAN abfackeln.
Wenn man jetzt natürlich im Keller eine Fritzbox stehen hat und unterm Dach noch gescheiten WLAN-Empfang haben will
für ein paar Geräte, dann sieht es natürlich schon wieder anders aus.
Aber da muss man sich halt auch Gedanken um sein WLAN-Setup machen. Dann funktioniert das eigentlich auch ganz gut.
Ich von allem...
Ich habe mittlerweile zwei Access-Points.
Ich habe einen Access-Point.
Ich habe einen Access-Point im Keller stehen und ein Access-Point hier oben gegenüber im Wohnzimmer an der Decke hängen.
Vollkommen ausreichend.
... smarten WLAN-Geräten getrennt.
Das Einzige, was ich jetzt noch habe, ist eine Goofy-Stablampe.
Und auch nur aus dem Grund, weil sie günstiger war als ihr Philips Hue-Äquivalent.
Und ansonsten geht halt einiges gar nicht ohne WLAN.
Wie machst du zum Beispiel eine RGB-Lampe?
Wie steuerst du die, wenn nicht über WLAN?
Dann kannst du ja schlechten Kabel dran machen.
... wollte, ob das Werbematerial das hält, was es verspricht.
Fun Fact, ich habe die Effekte genau einmal ausprobiert, als ich die Lampe aufgebaut habe und seitdem nie wieder.
Deswegen, wenn man sowas haben will...
Ach, über ZigBee, ja.
Aber, ich meine, wenn es Wireless ist...
Ich meine, ZigBee hat den Vorteil, dass du so ein bisschen Mesh von Haus aus bekommst mit mehreren Geräten.
Ja, das stimmt schon.
Kann man machen.
Kann auch Z-Wave verwenden.
Wobei ZigBee oder jetzt in Zukunft noch Meta...
Wobei das eigentlich...
Das eigentliche Protokoll ist ja Thread und Meta ist die logische Schicht obendrüber, die man auch über ZigBee machen kann.
Für solche Fälle, wenn es nicht so offen steht, könnte man beispielsweise auch LED-Strips benutzen mit WLED und einem kleinen Microcontroller dran.
Das ist deutlich günstiger und man kann viel mehr coole Sachen mitmachen.
Jetzt fristet sie ihr Dasein als normale Lampe und macht nur noch warmweiß oder wenn mal jemand klingelt, schaltet sie für 5 Sekunden auf blau.
Was mich aber wirklich stört, ist die lange Reaktionszeit.
Ich habe einen smarten Button bei uns im Esszimmer.
Ja, das Problem hat man mit WLED nicht.
Und das ist genau das, was ich sage.
Manche Leute übertreiben mit RGB-Beleuchtung.
Das ist mir auch schon aufgefallen.
Du brauchst keine RGB-Beleuchtung.
In der Regel reicht es dimmbar, also Remote an- und ausschaltbar, okay, dimmbar und eventuell die Farbtemperatur.
Fertig.
Mehr brauchst du zu 99% nicht.
Du brauchst nur an ganz wenigen Stellen, wo es dann auch wirklich Sinn macht.
Und das weißt du in der Regel auch explizit.
Und dass es da Sinn macht, RGB-Lampen.
Aufdrücke dauert es teilweise 3-4 Sekunden, bis die Lampe dann auch wirklich angeht.
Und das ist wirklich deutlich zu lange.
Vor allem im Gegensatz zu allen ZigBee-Geräten, die ich habe, die instant funktionieren.
ZigBee!
Oh, der ZigBee!
Ich dachte Home Assistant.
ZigBee!
Solltest du also mal ein cooles Licht sehen, was du haben möchtest und es läuft per WLAN, bedenke bitte das, was ich gerade gesagt habe.
Wenn du die Wahl hast.
Zwischen WLAN und ZigBee.
Benutze immer ZigBee.
Diese Geräte bauen ein eigenständiges Funknetzwerk auf und sind deutlich schneller als WLAN.
Das kann man so pauschal nicht sagen.
Das liegt am Gerät.
Also, ZigBee ist nicht per Default schneller als WLAN.
Das liegt einfach an dem Gerät.
Das ist...
Das macht keinen Sinn zu sagen, dass das prinzipiell schneller ist.
Äh...
Also, pingt mal irgendein WLAN-Gerät bei euch im WLAN-Netzwerk.
Das ist innerhalb von einer Millisekunde da.
Also, daran liegt es prinzipiell nicht.
Sondern an den Geräten selbst liegt das.
Außerdem wirst du vermehrt Thread-Geräte finden.
Diese arbeiten ähnlich wie ZigBee und bauen ein eigenes Netzwerk auf.
Da Thread natürlich jetzt der neue heiße Scheiß ist, solltest du dir gewahr sein, dass die Geräte etwas hochpreisiger sind.
Ja, wenn man viel Geld ausgeben will, kann man auch Z-Wave benutzen.
Also, ein ZigBee-Bewegungsmelder von Akara kostet...
...irgendwie um die 20 Euro.
Ein Thread-Bewegungsmelder von Eve kostet 40.
Aber das nur am Rande.
Wie gesagt, da WLAN-Geräte meistens etwas günstiger sind als ZigBee oder Thread-Geräte, gilt hier der Spruch...
...wer billig kauft, kauft zweimal.
Du wirst dich wirklich ärgern.
Nimm dir diesen Rat bitte wirklich, wirklich an.
Ich hab den Fehler gemacht.
Also, musst du ihn nicht machen.
Das ist wahrscheinlich einfach ein scheiß Gerät, wenn das so lange braucht.
Wie gesagt, WLED...
...über WLAN...
...ist überhaupt kein Ding.
Das ist auch...
...drückst du auf den Knopf, instant macht es was.
Nicht, dass es drei, vier Sekunden dauert.
Mit falschen Geräten meine ich Geräte, die nicht zu dem System passen, welches du zuhause benutzt.
In meinem Fall ist das Alexa.
Ich hab mir damals...
IH!
NO!
GOTT!
Wer macht denn sein Smart Home mit Alexa?
Äh!
Da muss irgendeine ordentliche zentrale Steuerungsgeschichte hin.
Am besten was, was lokal läuft.
Ohne Online-Abhängigkeit.
Und was sich auch mit verschiedenen Systemen integrieren lässt.
Es muss nicht zwangsläufig Home Assistant sein.
Es kann auch I.O. Broker, Open Hub oder sonst was sein.
Aber...
Alexa als reine Zentrale, ich weiß ja nicht.
Ich glaube, es war eine Lampe oder sowas gekauft.
Und die war nur HomeKit-fähig.
Das Problem war...
Das Schöne an Home Assistant ist, kannst du HomeKit auch einbinden.
Wie hast du denn das mit WLED gemacht unter Stromversorgung?
Äh...
Netzteil angeschlossen?
Achso!
Moment, das liegt nicht an WLED.
Das liegt daran, dass du nicht auf beiden Seiten Strom injectet hast.
Du musst den Strom an beiden Seiten vom LED-Strip anschließen.
Das ist normal.
Dass 5V-LED-Strips nach ein paar Metern die Farben nicht mehr richtig wiedergeben können.
Weil du zu viel Voltage-Drop hast.
Da bleiben halt von den 5V dann bloß noch 3,8V oder so über.
Das ist normal.
Du musst dann auf der anderen Seite auch noch Strom anschließen.
Oder, wenn es noch länger ist, musst du zwischendurch Strom injecten.
Oder aber...
Du benutzt keine 5V-LED-Strips, sondern 12V oder 24V-LED-Strips.
Da hast du das Problem nicht mit.
Das Problem, was du da hast, ist...
Du musst deinen Microcontroller irgendwie dran angeschlossen bekommen.
Und dann brauchst du irgendeinen Logic-Level-Shifter.
Dass das funktioniert.
Dass du dir deinen...
Und einen Spannungswandler.
Dass du dir deinen Microcontroller nicht grillst.
Das ist richtig.
Oder du legst das im Kreis.
Dass du mit dem Ende wieder dort rauskommst, wo du angefangen hast.
Ja.
Ja, du musst das Strom...
Ja, das ist so.
Wenn du das nicht willst, dann bieten sich vielleicht...
LED-Strips an, die nicht 5V verwenden.
Dann kannst du die viel, viel länger legen.
Also 24V...
Ich glaube 24V ist so das andere Gebräuchliche.
24V-LED-Strips, die haben das Problem mit der Farb...
Also mit den Farben, die nach einer Zeit runtergehen.
Also ein paar Meter verfälscht werden nicht.
Dafür musst du halt gucken, wie du deinen Microcontroller dran anschließt.
Was aber auch kein großartiges Problem ist.
Es gibt ja auch schon genug Teile.
Ansonsten, ja, musst du ein Kabel mitlegen.
Oder...
Etwas abzweigen, irgendwo anders.
Machen wir weiter.
Falsche Geräte.
An dem Zeitpunkt hatte ich HomeKit noch nicht.
Und ich dachte automatisch, alles was irgendwie smart ist, arbeitet mit Alexa zusammen.
Nö.
Dem ist natürlich nichts.
Es gibt sogar ganz viele Sachen, die nicht mit Alexa zusammenarbeiten.
Und auch Verkäufer beispielsweise bei Amazon wissen nicht immer, was ihre smarten Geräte, die sie da verkaufen, wirklich können und mit welchen Systemen sie zusammenarbeiten.
So hatte ich beispielsweise letztens mal das Problem, dass ich ein Angebot gesehen habe von Ledvans Lampen.
Und diese wollte ich mir kaufen, weil die sehr, sehr günstig waren.
Und es war ausdeklariert als HomeKit-fähige Lampe.
Als ich dann aber das Paket bekommen habe und es aufgemacht habe, wurde ich direkt angelacht von einem Works with Alexa-Sticker.
Und sonst nichts.
sonst nichts. Also habe ich das
zurückgeschickt und
musste dann halt damit leben, dass ich keine
günstigen Lampen für mein HomeKit zu Hause
habe. Oder man verwendet
irgendeine zentrale Steuereinheit, wo man
Alexa, HomeKit,
ZigBee, Z-Wave,
Thread, Meta, alles drüber,
irgendwelche Online-Services, alles zusammen
integrieren kann und man hat das Problem nicht mehr.
Wie gesagt, meine Geräte packe ich alle
in Home Assistant und die werden dann quasi
an die Sprachassistenten verwendet. Ja, aber wenn
er es doch in Home Assistant hat, wo ist das
Problem?
Hä?
Hä? Das geht doch.
Ich glaube mittlerweile kann Home Assistant
sogar HomeKit-Geräte standardmäßig
ansteuern.
Aber manchmal kaufe ich halt extra
Sachen, die nur mit HomeKit funktionieren,
einfach weil ich sie testen möchte,
so wie zum Beispiel meine Eve Motion oder
Eve Energy Geräte. Aber wie gesagt,
was ich dir damit sagen möchte ist,
pass bitte auf, was du
kaufst und wo du es kaufst.
Ja, das stimmt. Auch wenn es bei Amazon
beispielsweise steht, dass es
das und das System unterstützt,
schau besser nochmal selber nach
und recherchiere. Du bist damit auf der
sicheren Seite. Aber mit etwas Glück ist es...
Gut, sich überlegen, was man kauft, ist nie verkehrt.
... das Problem der Vergangenheit, denn Meta 1.0
ist gestartet. Irgendwann wird es also möglich
sein, dass wir in den Laden gehen oder bei Amazon
oder sonst irgendwo und uns einfach
ein Produkt aus dem Regal
nehmen können und dieses arbeitet
automatisch mit dem System, was wir haben,
zusammen. Bis das aber so weit ist,
gehen noch einige...
... habe ich meine 2.
Dafür kochen viel zu viele Hersteller
ihr eigenes Süppchen.
Und das wird,
ich sag's euch, das wird bei
Thread und Meta auch so sein,
das wird zwar prinzipiell miteinander kommunizieren
können, aber die Hersteller, gerade
an Xiaomi oder sowas, denke ich da,
die machen dann wieder irgendwelche eigenen
Extensions, die nur mit ihrem eigenen Scheiß
funktionieren. 100 pro, ich sag's euch.
So wird's sein.
... leider damit beschäftigen, vorher zu gucken,
welche Geräte mit welchem System
zusammenarbeiten.
Du solltest schauen, dass du deine Gerätekategorien
möglichst von einem Hersteller holst.
Warum?
Und zwar, damit meine ich Schalter
beispielsweise von Philips Hue,
Kameras von Ring oder
Bewegungsmelder von Eve.
Ring-Kameras kommen mir nicht
ins Hause. Die hatten übrigens letztens
Probleme als Amazon-Probleme.
Nee, warte mal. Doch Ring ist das
Zeug, was über AWS läuft, oder?
Ach, ich blick da nicht. Ich hab keine
und die kommen mir auch nicht wirklich ins Haus.
Beispielsweise verschiedenste
Schalter.
Wer ein Abo braucht, um meine eigenen Videos
anzugucken, der hört's auf.
Philips Hue bis Akara und
Ikea Tatfri. Das Problem ist
natürlich, dass nicht nur
Besucher, sondern auch die eigene Familie
und in dem Sinne meine Frau...
Ich hab billige China-Chinesen-Kameras im Einsatz,
die aber offline funktionieren.
Ohne App und ohne Internetverbindung.
Das sind zwar nicht die besten,
aber die funktionieren ganz brauchbar.
... dann irgendwann Probleme hat,
rauszufinden, welcher Schalter
für was überhaupt da ist.
Aber nicht nur meine Frau hat Probleme.
Teilweise hab ich selber Probleme.
Ich habe extra diese Philips Hue-Schalter geholt
und habe da, wie man sieht,
Custom-Sticker drauf gemacht,
damit man immer weiß, für was die einzelnen Tasten
wirklich da sind.
Bei manchen Schaltern geht das einfach gar nicht.
Oder es sieht total beknackt aus.
Und auch das Problem, wenn mal Besuch da ist
und beispielsweise hinter mir ist eine Couch,
das ist eine Schlafcouch, da können
meine Schwiegereltern schlafen
und wenn die dann auf einmal
irgendeine fremde Femme-Jung sehen,
die wissen gar nicht, wie das Licht ausgeht.
Und das ist ein Problem.
Ja, das kann ich mir vorstellen.
Auf jeden Fall deine Geräte-Klassen
von einem Hersteller holen,
einfach damit es eine Linie ergibt.
Außerdem, beim Beispiel Kamera
wäre es natürlich ein bisschen kontraproduktiv,
wenn du drei verschiedene Hersteller hast
und drei verschiedene Kameras...
Also bei Kameras habe ich
zwei verschiedene Hersteller.
Einmal habe ich noch ein paar alte
Wisecams selbst geflasht
und dann habe ich noch ein paar
Reolink-billig-China-Chinesen-Kamera.
Aber halt auch, weil die rein offline funktioniert.
...drei verschiedene Apps
und nicht unbedingt jede Kamera arbeitet
mit dem System zusammen, welches du hast.
Schau also vorher, was du dir leisten kannst,
was du dir leisten willst
und was für dich am besten aussieht.
Mache nicht den Fehler, den ich habe
und hol dir von drei bis vier verschiedenen Herstellern
verschiedene Schalter.
Das ist überhaupt kein Problem,
solange die das gleiche System unterstützen.
Du kannst drei verschiedene Kameras holen
und von allen drei per RTSP abgreifen.
Geht, das ist überhaupt kein Ding.
Ich hoffe, ich konnte dir mit diesem Video
ein bisschen helfen und zeigen...
Bei einigen Sachen stimme ich zu,
allerdings bei vielen nicht.
...wenn du ein ähnliches...
Oha!
How to kill a YouTube-Video.
Das ist bestimmt wieder G-Bait.
Die Videos von ihm sind immer 90% Hype aufgebaut
und dann kommt irgendwas recht Banales.
Ausnahmen bestätigen die Regel.
Lassen wir uns lassen.
Ne, das gucken wir uns jetzt nicht an.
Er hilft Menschen im Alltag.
Aufgaben, lohnt sich das als...
Oh ne, ne, ne, ne.
Das ist soziale Berufe, Alter.
Ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne.
Das kann ich mir noch nicht mal angucken.
Das würde ich im Leben nicht machen.
Haben wir sonst noch irgendwas?
Mit diesem Teil...
Moment, das kennen wir doch schon.
Network Chuck, ja.
Muss ich sagen, interessiert mich zum größten Teil nicht so.
Acht Webseiten, die dein Leben leichter machen.
Das ist bestimmt G-Bait.
Da ist bestimmt nichts Gescheites dabei.
Okay, wir gucken uns das Video jetzt nicht an.
Wir gucken uns einfach unten die Kapitel an.
Also, Stockfotos.
Das ist tatsächlich nice.
Verwende ich auch ab und zu.
Die sind gut.
Canva ist tatsächlich auch ganz nice.
I have been pwned ist nice.
Temporäre E-Mail-Adresse stellen.
Ja, gut.
Brauche ich nicht mehr.
Ich erstelle jetzt alles auf meiner eigenen Domain.
Mit E-Mail-Weiterleitung.
WeTransfer.
Ja.
Das ist gar nicht schlecht.
Corn, warum 0w?
Ich finde das teilweise tatsächlich ganz praktisch.
Online-Weiterbildung und Google-Zukunftswerkstatt.
Was?
Standard.
Ja, das ist billig.
Package-Manager für Windows.
Brauchen wir nicht.
Okay, müssen wir uns nicht angucken.
Easy.
Zack.
Skipped.
Outdated.
Overrated.
G-Baited.
10 Must-Try-Visual-Codeos.
Must-Try.
Das ist tatsächlich ein relativ interessantes Video.
Im Endeffekt schalte reguläres Video von anderen als Werbung für unwichtige Zielgruppen.
Video.
Matrix.
Bad Algorithmus.
Also sprich, du kannst das Video von jemand anderem als Werbung promoten lassen.
Irgendwo in einem Benutzerkreis, wo sie es nicht interessiert.
Und dann sagt der Algorithmus des Videos sagt.
Aha.
Verstehe.
Wie genau funktioniert das mit meiner eigenen Domain?
Ich habe mir eine Domain gekauft.
Und habe bei Cloudflare.
Benutze den Cloudflare-Disk.
Benutze den Cloudflare-DNS dafür.
Und bei Cloudflare kannst du E-Mail-Weiterleitungen einrichten.
Zum Beispiel kannst du dann blue-sky-at-blub-blub-blub.com als E-Mail-Weiterleitung einrichten.
Die an deine normale E-Mail-Adresse geht.
Das heißt, ich habe quasi nahezu unendlich E-Mail-Adressen auf meinen paar Domains.
Und kann die weiterleiten lassen an eine zentrale E-Mail-Adresse.
Installing Linux on a Nintendo Wii.
Wie das geht?
Was haben die denn für Kameras zu bieten?
Sie sehen, das sind doch bestimmt auch ganz normale China-Chinesen-Kameras.
Umgelabelt.
Oder?
50 Euro?
Für 50 Euro sehe ich hier nichts.
Ich sehe, dass hier was 10.000 Euro kostet.
Für 50, für 5 Preis aufsteigend.
So Dome-Kameras.
Sind die...
Die große Preisfrage ist...
Nehmen wir erstmal beispielsweise sowas hier.
Sind die lokal?
Ja, die haben...
Okay, okay, okay.
Das ist in Ordnung.
Sind aber wahrscheinlich so nicht wasserdicht.
Haben PoE.
Irgendeinen China-Chinesen-Reprint.
Aber okay.
Die haben PoE und haben Netzwerkkabel.
Ist die Frage RTSP lokal?
Geht das?
Und Web-Interface zum Einrichten?
Okay, dann hat die auch RTSP.
Ja...
Solange man nicht die offizielle App von denen braucht,
sondern die auch über das Web-Interface einrichten kann,
ist es wahrscheinlich...
War immer so verkehrt, ne?
Aber so Dome-Kameras braucht man ja meistens nicht.
Viele Dome-Kameras.
RTSP ist für Kamera-Videostreams.
Warum ist die so schepp?
Ah, ist eine Weitwinkel-Kamera.
Ach so, das war nur von der Seite.
Sieht fast ein bisschen aus wie eine 3D-Brille.
White people happy.
Ja, ich hoffe, dass die auch ohne Cloud auskommt.
Wow!
Ja, könnte man sich mal angucken.
Installing...
Da bin ich mal gespannt.
Linux auf der Wii.
Ich habe meine Wii leider weggeschmissen.
...everybody's favorite Nintendo-Console from 2006.
And we're gonna be screwing around with it today,
because we're going to attempt to install Linux on this console.
That's right.
Now, I figured this was pretty appropriate,
because it was a year ago this month,
when I did the PlayStation 2 Linux video
using Sony's official PS2 Linux kit.
This method we're gonna take a look at on the Wii here
is certainly not official at all.
This was not a Nintendo-sanctioned thing.
And it's only thanks to the work of some people
in the Wii homebrewing community
that we're even able to do this in the first place.
So yes, if it wasn't already obvious,
Nintendo Wii with Bootme installed.
And then you're also going to need an SD-Card
and a USB-Flashdrive.
The two things to make any homebrew project successful.
At least in theory, anyways.
Und man kann an der Wii auch nur am linken USB-Anschluss
sowas anschließen. Das ist ganz merkwürdig.
Ich erinnere mich noch daran.
Zumindest als ich mal selbst mit meiner Wii damals rumexperimentiert habe.
Du konntest nur den einen USB-Anschluss verwenden,
für sowas nicht den anderen.
Let's go ahead and swap over to my computer
and we'll get started with this.
Alright, so getting Linux installed on the Nintendo Wii
is actually relatively simple.
And I'm gonna kinda walk you through that process here.
There are a couple of distros that you could use,
believe it or not.
We've got White, or Wheat perhaps,
if you're pronouncing it like the I's in Wii.
But whatever. White, Blight, and X-White.
Aha.
Debian?
Wait a minute, Debian 5.0?
Wisst ihr, wie alt das ist?
Ja gut, 2008.
In Blight Linux,
which is down here under third party distros,
is based on Gentoo.
Beste.
Gentoo.
Arch, Arch by the way,
gibt's auch noch.
It is White Linux
with a GUI. It's got X included as well.
Aber kann das sein, dass die Distros
alle ur-ur-ur-ural sind?
So, we're just going to use that for this video.
But theoretically you could use any of these three
with the installer,
which is the far...
...or easier method of installing Linux on the Wii.
You could go through the method of manually installing
one of these other distros,
if you would prefer to do that,
or just with White Linux,
or Blight Linux,
or whichever one that you want.
But it's definitely quite the...
Die große Preisfrage natürlich,
die sich jetzt einem stellt, ist,
warum?
Außer um's zu machen, weil es geht.
Also, was ist der Mehrwert dadurch?
Man kann die Wii nicht mehr für das benutzen,
was sie gemacht wurde.
Und man kann damit auch nix machen mehr.
Also, irgendwie so wirklich...
Es geht halt, ja.
...ordeal that you have to go through here.
And they made this installer to just make the process a lot easier.
So we're going to be taking advantage of that.
Vor wann ist das Video? Vor einem Monat.
All of this info is really old.
Over ten years old, okay?
You saw like from the date here on,
which was at this page here,
this version was released in 2008, 2009.
So this stuff is like pretty old.
But we did come across this post over on GBA Temp,
that was posted in 2020.
That is a guide on how to get
ex-white Linux running on the Wii
and get WiFi working.
Which is pretty great.
We're going to try that out later on in this video as well.
Now you need to have a homebrewed Wii
with BootMe installed.
If you don't have a homebrewed Wii,
I'd recommend going over to wii.guide
and following along the tutorial here.
Once you get the homebrewed channel
and BootMe installed, then you can come back to this page.
And you have to download a couple of things
from this page which you can open right away.
So this is openness of the game.
The all-in-one-way mode.
I hope you will like and 만들어
your own problems.
Another thing.
This is how mobile games are in TES.
Let me fokj me and this looks interesting.
And again,
I don't know if this is real,
but I don't know how a computer
memorized supports that iş
with band aids.
I'm missing some new stuff.
Lots very interesting parts.
Princess, der Pferdename
war zu lang. Und du
musstest dann quasi
Twilight Princess starten,
den Spielstand laden, du musstest
glaube ich, wenn ich das richtig im Kopf habe, rückwärts
zu einem NPC
laufen und dann mit dem
NPC reden und wenn der
NPC den Namen vom
Pferd ausgesprochen hat,
gab es irgendwie einen Buffer-Overflow, weil der
Name vom Pferd im Spielstand zu lange war
und dann ist er genau auf die
Adresse von
deinem USB-Stick gesprungen und du
konntest vom USB-Stick irgendwie Code
nachladen. Das war total
Weirdchamp damals, wie
das funktioniert hat.
Richtig higher Q-Graph.
Mittlerweile ist das einfach.
Es gibt ja seit Jahren schon diesen
Banner-Trick mit der Wii,
dass du einfach was anklicken musst auf der SD-Karte
und das Ding ist geroutet quasi.
Aber das war schon geil.
2.7Z-Files in here
and one of these has to go on your
SD-Card, one of them has to go on your
USB-Flashdrive. So we're gonna start
with the SD-Card, which should look
something like this.
Ach ja, und Nintendo konnte das übrigens auch nie
patchen, weil die Wii
so ein ganz komisches System hatte
aus Firmware. Du hattest zwar die
Firmware in deinem Flash, aber das hatte
immer auch rückwärtskompatibel
alle alten Firmwares
drin oder alle alten Firmware-Interfaces
drin, weil die Wii hatte quasi,
ein Teil der Firmware im Flash
und ein Teil der Firmware
im Game.
Das heißt, die konnten nie was wegwerfen,
weil sonst alte Games nicht mehr laufen würden,
die früher rausgekommen sind. Ganz, ganz merkwürdiges
Zeug, was Nintendo da gebaut hat.
Sie konnten das auch nie patchen.
Wir spulen mal ein bisschen vor. So genau
muss ich mir das jetzt nicht angucken.
Okay, der Homebrew-Channel.
Nicer Fernseher, den er hier
am Start hat.
Es sieht halt auch schon so schön
Oldschool-Wii-mäßig aus.
Debian-Installer.
Ja, Debian-Installer
auf der Wii stelle ich mir vor, dauert bestimmt
zwei Stunden oder sowas.
Das ist lahm, as fuck.
Opera 9-2!
Das ist wirklich aus grauer Vorzeit,
was da gerade installiert wird.
War die Wii eigentlich nur ein Gamecube
mit Gestensteuerung? Naja, nee, nee.
Die Wii war prinzipiell die gleiche
Hardware wie der Gamecube, aber mit schnellerer
Grafikkarte und übertakteter CPU.
Also übertakteter, schnellerer.
CPU und schnellerer Grafikkarte.
Es war aber gleich, es war ein IBM
Power-PC.
Power, Power, ja, Power-PC
heißt das Ding, glaube ich, von der Architektur her und auch die
gleiche Grafikkarte, soweit ich weiß.
Es war quasi ein schnellerer
Gamecube mit Gestensteuerung.
Ja, das stimmt schon.
Das ist nicht, ich meine, 16 Minuten,
wenn es tatsächlich 16, 20 Minuten ist,
das ist nicht zu schlecht.
Es dauert ewig, der Install.
Und da sind wir, wir sind fertig.
Es hat nicht mal 15 Minuten gedauert.
Was, nur 15 Minuten?
Das geht sogar.
So, we're going to hit OK
to reboot the video console, alright.
And it said that it was copying over
a ppcboot.elf
file, so I'm wondering if we even need to
copy over the version
that was mentioned in that guide.
We're gonna see, because it said you can launch it right now
from the homebrew channel, so
let's just try it and see.
So,
the SD card has had
the installer wiped, so nothing's gonna show up.
We're gonna press the home button
and go down to launch bootme.
And we'll see what happens.
Yeah, it's booting.
And
it just ejected the
disk, which is interesting.
But yeah, here it is, it's starting the desktop manager.
So I wonder why
this guy said he needed to stop you
for the help.
Und kann damit im Prinzip jetzt nichts mehr machen,
was ich mit der Konsole sonst machen könnte.
Aber ich habe ein 15 Jahre altes Debian am Start.
Einfach nur, weil es geht. Man wird das nicht machen.
Man kann das für nichts verwenden.
Aber hey, es funktioniert.
And by the way, this is all done off the SD card.
You don't need to have the USB drive
plugged into the Wii anymore.
So I've plugged a mouse into the other USB port.
And
yeah, let's view the about information.
So we'll go about XFCE.
And this is version 4, copyright
02 to 06.
And
yeah, XFCE 4 version 4.3
.99.2
But yeah, I mean, here it is. We've got
the dock down here. We've got
our icons on the desktop.
But we also have, let's see, we've got programming.
Woah, Bison 2.4!
Poggers!
Bash and SH. Sound.
We've got some sound stuff.
Just talk a little bit more about this
ppcboot.l file that I was mentioning.
Tastatur kann man anschließen. Maus? Weiß nicht.
Vielleicht muss man ja die Wiimote verwenden.
Ne, wahrscheinlich geht auch eine Maus.
Wobei, man hat ja kein USB. Doch, man hat wieder
ne, hat man überhaupt
genug USB-Ports?
Turns out, there is a very
good reason why we have to change out
the file with the one that the
text tutorial guide mentioned. And that's because
the installer we used installs
version 2.6.27
of the Linux Kernel. Aha.
But the latest version of the Linux Kernel that was
compiled for the Wii, at least through this project,
was 2.6.32.
2.6
Kernel. Alter,
das ist so alt.
And that's the version that is contained
in the ELF file that the
installer gave us.
Also, it just seemed like the right thing to do.
But, anyways, with all of that said,
let's go ahead and jump into the
Homebrew channel again.
And we will launch Bootme from here.
Eigentlich hab ich dich nicht verpasst zu
subscriben. Ich hab sogar was gesagt.
Verpasste selten subs.
And then we'll go through the process
of trying to
and, you know,
W-H-I-I believe.
And we've got dash on that.
So, failed to bring up
WLAN 0.
It's just so much more convenient.
Of course, when you have easy
access to it.
So now, I should be able to.
Terminals come up here.
Google.com. Oh, there we go.
Yes, let's go. We're online,
people. Oh my gosh, that is beautiful.
Geil, ich bin online mit nem Debian
von 2008 auf ner Konsole.
Egal, es geht. Es geht.
Es geht. Nicht, dass es in irgendeiner Art und Weise
sinnvoll wäre, aber Hauptsache es geht.
Hat das Ding überhaupt genug
RAM um nen Browser zu öffnen?
Die Wii hatte doch so gut wie kein RAM, oder?
Okay, nee, nee, nee,
geht noch hier. Na doch, na doch.
Na, geht, geht halbwegs.
64, 64 MB.
Nein, nein, die Wii
hatte doch keine 512. Die Wii hat kaum RAM.
That may have been because we forced
power off the system.
And let's try to go to Google.com.
Google geht, Google geht immer.
Not .cm, not Google.cm.
Well, that also works,
but Google.com.
Er soll mal YouTube aufmachen.
Der lädt die Seite noch nicht wahr.
Weil Google erstmal, allein schon,
weil YouTube erstmal 78 MB
JavaScript nachladen muss, damit es überhaupt
funktioniert. Und auch HTML5
abspielen wird damit nicht möglich sein.
Das ist ungefähr so, wie wenn ich Firefox
oder Windows 98 benutze.
Als Headless-Server?
Quatsch, wozu?
Die wird wahrscheinlich mehr verbrauchen als
Single-Board-Computer. Das ist total
usle. Also, mir fällt kein, wirklich
absolut gar kein sinnvoller
Anwendungszweck dafür ein.
Vor allem mit Software von 2008.
Also, es gibt eine ganze
Results-Page, die meistens passiert.
Äh, ja, weiter, das ist gut.
Ja, da sind wir.
Wir werden überhaupt nicht
auf YouTube gehen können.
Nö, das wird nicht funktionieren.
Nun, das beantwortet das.
Es geht erst gar nicht auf.
Guck mal, der ist so alt, dass der
aktuelle HTTPS-Seiten gar nicht mehr
aufmachen kann.
So, lass uns versuchen,
hey, das ist gut, nintendo.com.
Lass uns in 2008
sehen.
Es sieht so aus, als hätte
diese Page relativ gut
vorgesehen.
Ähm, es sieht so aus, als wäre Wii-Musik
in dieser Zeit rausgekommen.
Experience Wii.
Experience Nintendo DS.
Kirby Superstar Ultra, Mann.
World of Goo, oh mein Gott,
das war ein ziemlich lustiges Spiel.
Das Spiel war wirklich cool.
Ich habe es auf dem Wii
erst gespielt.
Ich glaube, es war Wii Shop Channel.
Eigentlich möchte ich mal
schauen, was das für eine Scheiße ist.
Oh, das tut weh.
Also, das ist so groß, wie groß
die Package-Selektion ist.
Oder zumindest eine Teil der Schicht.
Ja, das ist das letzte,
was ich da drauf machen würde, Alter.
Ich muss das gleiche hier machen.
Für eine richtige
Ah, ja, es ist so
Drossel.
Und zuerst
Dvd.
Das würde mich fast wundern,
wenn man da drauf eine Dvd abspielen kann,
obwohl es den Dvd-Laufwerk hat.
Okay, und lasst uns
File, Open Disk
Let's just go with the defaults
and hit okay, and play.
We've got no drive activity.
Ich glaube nicht, dass es funktioniert,
dass es das Wii-Ding als normales
Dvd-Drive erkennt.
Das glaube ich nicht.
Now, it did mention, there was experimental
support for the Wii's DVD Drive
and it didn't say anything about playing
like DVDs through VLC.
I'm just trying this out.
But it's definitely not
looking good here.
Das wird nicht funktionieren.
...
Right click.
Okay, open.
Nee, wird nicht funktionieren.
Something did go wrong, of course.
Es macht halt absolut keinen Sinn.
Cool, dass es geht.
Und jetzt next.
Das ist echt cool.
Das ist so ein Ding,
das kann man einmal ausprobieren,
weil es irgendwie cool ist,
das mal gesehen zu haben,
aber dann ist es halt unsinnig.
Man könnte sagen Zeitverschwendung,
wobei ich sagen muss,
sowas zu basteln, wenn es einem Spaß macht,
ist ja nie Zeitverschwendung.
Es macht keinen Sinn.
Unterm Strich macht es wirklich keinen Sinn.
Was haben wir hier noch?
Top 10 Visual Studio Code Extensions
you must try.
Okay.
Dann lassen wir uns doch kurz erklären,
was wir hier tryen müssen.
...
... ...
Das ist tatsächlich ganz praktisch.
Super Console-Log.
Oh, das ist für alle Javascript.
Wie ist das passende E-Mode?
Keck Javascript.
Ich sehe gar nichts.
Ach so, das fügt...
Moment, das ist ein...
Ich füge für dich ein Console-Log ein.
Eigentlich ganz praktisch.
Ja, nachdem man Javascript ja auch
gerade mit...
wenn du was im Browser laufen lässt,
was du auch
ganz gerne mal so oldschool Printline
debuggen musst.
Ganz nützlich, tatsächlich.
Ne, das ist Mist, das kenn ich. Das gefällt mir nicht.
Liveshare ist tatsächlich ganz nice.
Git-History, ich benutze
keine Gits. Kein Git im Editor.
Ich mach nur Git-Kommandozeile,
weil beste.
Jetzt haben wir Git-History.
Jetzt gibt es ein paar Extensions,
die ähnlich sind wie Git-Lens und so weiter.
Aber ich mag einfach nur
die Simplizität hier.
Ich habe dieses File hier.
Ich benutze es nicht.
Für Keck-Javascript-User
Auto-Rename-Tag.
Ich liebe diese Extensions,
die mir mit diesen kleinen Bitten helfen,
die ziemlich faszinierend sind.
Und Coding.
Und ich habe dieses Main-Tag.
Und ich entscheide, ich will kein Main-Tag.
Ich will ein Div.
Weil ich Accessibility hasse
und ich will, dass jeder leidet.
Also will ich das renamen.
Aber ich rename das und dann muss ich
auf der anderen Seite suchen.
Und besonders, wenn man Divs zusammenstellt.
Stagged? Tagged.
Tagged zusammen.
Stacked. Zusammen.
Was bin ich denn?
Es ist schwieriger zu finden, welches Div welches ist.
Du kannst einfach das, was du willst.
Wie dieses Main.
Und ich kann es in ein Div verwenden.
Und ich brauche nicht mehr hier runter zu gehen
und das andere zu finden.
Es wird es automatisch für mich renamen.
Das ist wirklich hilfreich.
Das ist tatsächlich ganz praktisch.
Sprechend über Dinge, die schwer zu sehen sind.
Kann das Visual Studio Code nicht mittlerweile von Haus aus
Ich bilde mir ein, ich habe da was gesehen.
Dass das mittlerweile Brackets ordentlich
highlighten kann.
Brackets, richtig?
Sie sehen alle gleich aus.
Das ist anders.
Da gibt es zig solcher Plugins.
Rainbow Brackets
und hast du nicht gesehen.
Das ist tatsächlich ganz praktisch.
Das ist tatsächlich ganz nützlich.
Da kann man quasi die Zugehörigkeit
der Klammer sehen.
Unabhängig von Einrückung und alles.
Wie gesagt, ich wollte gerade sagen,
ich bilde mir ein.
Das ist teilweise mittlerweile Build-In.
Was haben wir sonst noch?
Autoimportkosten.
Das juckt mich nicht.
Und das Video, da sieht man mal,
wie schnell in der JavaScript-Welt
was passiert.
Das Video ist erst
5 Monate alt und schon komplett
outdated, overrated,
jebaited.
Never donated, free entertainment,
Prime subbed,
Neighbors WiFi.
Ich kaufe 3D-Druckkatapulte
für 5,50.
Wen juckt es?
Oh Mann.
Drei lustige Terminal-Kommandos.
Massive funny.
Okay, gucken wir mal,
wie lustig die sind.
Drei lustige Terminal-Kommandos.
Ich habe nichts gegen das Videospielen.
Ich habe ein Stück nach unten gescrollt.
Alter, YouTube, please.
Drei lustige Terminal-Kommandos.
Wenn du dich beim Eingeben
eines Kommandos vertippst,
kannst du direkt danach f*** eintippen
und der Fehler wird korrigiert.
Nummer 2, Htop.
Das ist für Linux wie der Task Manager
auf Windows oder die Aktivitätsanzeige
Das ist nicht lustig, das funktioniert einfach.
Das Ganze sieht aber so aus,
als seid ihr die krassesten Hacker überhaupt.
Nummer 3, AFire.
Perfekt für die kalte Jahreszeit,
kannst du dir ein gemütliches Lagerfeuer
direkt in deinem Terminal anzeigen lassen.
Also ich finde, Htop ist sehr lustig,
weil man sieht, was sein System
für Auslastungen hat. Vor allem,
wenn das CPU-Decoding von Videos
nicht funktioniert, dann sieht man nämlich,
dass unter Linux Videos im Browser angucken
einfach 80% CPU-Last brauchen.
Wie viel Geld solltest du
bis wann gespart haben?
Okay, gucken wir mal.
Definitiv, wie groß...
Zeig mal her.
Wie viel muss ich schon gespart haben?
Also zeig mal her, ich bin jetzt 38.
Okay.
Hä?
Jetzt blicke ich nicht mehr durch.
Was muss ich machen?
Stonks.
Okay, ich hätte das Video vielleicht doch gucken sollen.
Anfrage dieses Videos, wie viel Vermögen
muss ich heute schon gespart haben,
um mein Vermögensziel mit 10%
Sparquote erreichen zu können?
Dazu müssen wir die ganze Rechnung nochmal
von hinten aufrollen, denn das Vermögen,
was ich heute habe, arbeitet ja auch schon
heute für mich. Ich profitiere also schon
vom Zinseszins-Effekt...
Also ich sehe das, wie gut das gerade,
wenn ich in meine Stonks-App gucke,
ich sehe das, wie gut das für mich arbeitet.
Ich gucke mal kurz rein.
Ähm...
Das arbeitet exzellent.
Do you want to use Face-ID?
Ja, meinetwegen.
Hey, es ist sogar wieder ein bisschen hochgegangen, Leute!
Ui!
Die Stonks, Leute!
Die Stonks gehen richtig hoch die letzten Wochen!
Allerdings...
Allerdings bin ich immer noch
930 Euro im Minus.
Aber die Stonks sind, ohne Scheiß,
die letzte...
Die letzte Woche
ist es einfach extrem hochgegangen.
... heute bis zum Renteneintritt.
Es reicht also nicht, einfach nur
den benötigten Betrag von dem abzuziehen,
was ich ersparen kann, sondern,
wenn ich heute schon Geld zur Verfügung habe,
dann arbeitet das ja auch heute schon für mich
und das müssen wir mit berücksichtigen.
Wem das Ganze zu kompliziert ist, der kann sich auch gerne mal
die Excel-Tabelle zu diesem Video anschauen
in der Videobeschreibung. Kommen wir jetzt einmal
zu den Ergebnissen nach Alterskategorie eingeordnet.
Bei den 25-Jährigen haben wir ja schon
festgestellt, dass wir hier gar kein
Startkapital benötigen. Minus! Bei den 30-Jährigen
brauchen wir schon ein wenig Startkapital,
nämlich ca. 12.000 Euro.
Und je höher wir in der Alterskategorie steigen,
desto größer ist natürlich das Kapital, was benötigt
wird, um die Rentenlücke zu schließen.
Ja gut, man hat ja nicht mehr so viel Zeit.
Ja, das ist klar.
Okay, da bin ich drüber.
Die Zeit bis zur Rente
ist ja auch nochmal viel kürzer.
Sollte also euer aktueller Vermögensstand geringer
sein als in dieser Tabelle, müsst ihr
vermutlich eure Sparquote anpassen.
Und jetzt ist natürlich die Frage,
auf wie viel Prozent meines Einkommens muss ich denn
meine Sparquote schrauben, um meine
Rentenlücke noch schließen zu können.
Auch das haben wir für euch nochmal ausgerechnet.
Und das seht ihr hier. Bei den unter 25-Jährigen
sind es sogar weniger als 10%.
Nichtsdestotrotz würde ich euch trotzdem
empfehlen, mindestens 10% auf
die Seite zu legen. Das sollte wirklich die absolute
Mindestsparrate sein.
Denn ihr möchtet ja auch nicht nur Geld für die Rente
auf die Seite legen, sondern vielleicht auch noch für andere
Dinge. Ab der Kategorie 30 Jahre
und darüber hinaus steigt dann die Sparquote,
bis dann teilweise in ein...
Bei 60 muss man 155%
sparen. Easy.
... sehr unrealistischen Bereich von 48%
bei den 50-Jährigen,
80% bei den 55-Jährigen
und sogar mehr als 100% bei den
60-Jährigen. Das ist natürlich nicht
sonderlich realistisch. Da muss man natürlich
entweder schon... Ja gut.
Stonks.
Der Kerl wieder.
Das gucken wir jetzt nicht an. Ich will bloß, dass
das Video verschwindet. Deswegen muss man es kurz mal
anklicken. So.
Das war's. Leute, ich geh jetzt was essen.
Um 11.17. Ich geh jetzt nichts essen.
Oder ich geh doch was essen.
Ich hab Hunger.
Ich kann auch schon um 11.15
was essen. Ist gar kein Problem.
Easy.
Eats.
Geh jetzt was futtern, Leute.
Das Ende von YouTube, so wie wir es kennen.
Oh, das ist wieder so ein leichtes...
Moment. Leichtes...
Klingt nach leichtem Clickbait.
Was der deutsche Gesetzgeber da jetzt wieder plant,
ist der absolute Hammer.
Vordergründig geht's um gutes Ziel
Stärkung der Demokratie.
Aber was dabei herausgekommen ist, ist eine
Veränderung der sozialen Medien,
wie es sie so noch nie gegeben hat.
Eure Sehgewohnheiten
auf YouTube sollen zwangsweise
verändert werden. Das heißt... Warum?
Ihr könnt künftig nicht mehr Rezo am Stück gucken
oder Monte am Stück gucken, sondern es soll Bildung...
Oder Wobblos am Stück gucken.
Von wann ist dieses Video? Von gestern.
... eingebaut werden in die YouTube-Streams.
Das Ganze geht zurück auf eine
EU-Richtlinie, die ich euch hier schon mal
vor einiger Zeit vorgestellt habe.
Diese EU-Richtlinie... Ist das vom 1. April?
Das ist vom 1. April.
Das ist... Okay.
Das ist es, ähm...
Das ist eindeutig Debate.
Ja.
Dann gucken wir das jetzt nicht.
Wollte grad sagen, das hätte ja auch ein bisschen mehr...
bisschen mehr Wind gemacht sonst.
D-debated.
Okay, Leute. Ich geh jetzt wirklich was essen.
Bis denn.
Aber geht's denn so lang, Orn?
Ich muss jetzt nicht wieder 4-5 Stunden labern am Stück.
Äh...
Reicht mir.
Bis denn. Macht's gut.
Cu. PippoFatTime.